So, was meint ihr, was das ist? Freundeslisten, genau. Das ist euer Facebook-Profil ausgedruckt. Das ist quasi all das, was du in Facebook bist. Da ist jemand ein bisschen sauer auf dich, kann das sein?
Was erkennst du denn so an Informationen direkt auf den ersten Blick, die du kritisch findest, die du seltsam findest, dass wir die haben?
Ja, meine Nachrichten. Weil das eigentlich private Sachen sind, die ich da schreibe und dann kann es jetzt jemand lesen.
Ja klar, hier steht, das war der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens. Ist dir das bewusst gewesen, dass man das alles so lesen kann? Und wie findest du das?
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zur 189. Ausgabe dieser Sendereihe und ja, es ist immer noch 2011, zumindest für mich, weiß was ich, wann ihr das so hört. Und wie das immer so ist, Ende des Jahres gibt es da diese ganz spezielle Veranstaltung, den Chaos Communication Congress, der gerade stattfindet, der 28. Und ja, das gibt immer die Gelegenheit dann hier und da auch gleich mal ein paar Leute vor Ort zu verhaften, zum Gespräch einzuladen. Und insofern geht es auch dieses Mal um ein Thema, was auf der einen Seite viel mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun hat, auf der anderen Seite aber auch so ein ureigenes Thema, speziell der deutschen Hacker-Szene auch aufgreift. Im Kern geht es hier um ein CMS, aber um ein anderes CMS, als ihr jetzt denkt. Es geht um das Projekt Chaos macht Schule. Und dazu begrüße ich gleich zwei Gäste, nämlich den Peter, Peter Hecko.
Servus.
Auch als Hackpeet unterwegs und Florian, Florian Grunow. Genannt Jorn. Und ihr seid aus Mannheim.
Korrekt.
Und der wievielte Kongress ist das so für euch?
Ich glaube, 21 wäre glaube ich unser erster. Kann es sein?
Ich glaube auch, ein oder 22.
Ja, irgend sowas, ja.
Es war auf jeden Fall in der Nähe von 23, weil da erinnert man sich dran.
Und was nehmt ihr immer so mit auf dem Kongress?
Ja, neue Kontakte auf jeden Fall, schöne neue Projekte, Inspiration auf jeden Fall, auch für Chaos macht Schule. Und das sind so die hauptsächlichen Sachen.
Also ich nehme auf jeden Fall mit, dass ich die ganzen Leute, die ich halt das Ganze ja nur irgendwie online sehe oder chatte oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Twitter, Jabbar, wie auch immer, die einfach mal persönlich zu treffen, um mal wieder mit denen face to face zu sprechen, das ist glaube ich eine ganz, ganz wichtige Sache und auch eine ganz wichtige Komponente für diesen Kongress. Natürlich auch das Vortragsprogramm ist hier jetzt mal wieder spitzenmäßig, aber über die Jahre hat man sich dann so ein paar spezielle Vorträge ausgepickt und probiert halt natürlich dann mehr zu socialisieren und mehr mit der Community sich zu unterhalten, als da jetzt Vorträge sich anzugucken.
Chaos macht Schule, das ist ein Projekt, wo ihr sehr persönlich auch sehr engagiert seid. Dahinter steht die Idee, quasi so das Hackerwissen ein bisschen in die Schulen zu tragen, mal salopp formuliert. Jetzt ist ja das eigentlich auch schon immer so ein Thema gewesen, finde ich zumindest so im Club-Umfeld, Stichwort Medienkompetenz. Ich glaube, das ist so das erste Buzzword, was so durch die Lande geschickt wurde. Man klagte sie immer ein, man bemängelte sie und hat sie irgendwie gefordert, dass alle möglichen Leute sie entwickeln sollen. Insbesondere halt immer in dieser Frage, wie gehen wir grundsätzlich so mit der Bildung um? Wie seid ihr denn auf dieses Thema gekommen? Was ist denn überhaupt euer Hintergrund? Peter, was hast du so gemacht?
Ich bin ganz klassisch Studienabbrecher, Informatik und dann halt irgendwas mit Computern gemacht.
Das ist ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium-Vorweisen.
Dementsprechend bin ich halt zum richtigen Zeitpunkt im richtigen Ort gewesen und hab da halt irgendwas mit Computern gemacht. Dann geht es halt irgendwie weiter, weiter, weiter. Letzten Endes landet man halt bei irgendeinem Großkonzern und kümmert sich halt dann irgendwie um Infrastruktur und Netze und so ein Krempe. Also ich habe jetzt keinen pädagogischen Background, wo ich sagen würde, ich habe da irgendwie Fachkenntnis in dieser Richtung.
Also ich mache gerade meinen Master's in Software Engineering in Mannheim und habe auch keinerlei pädagogische Vorkenntnisse oder so. Das war auch eine Sache, die bei unseren ersten Projekten irgendwie uns so die größten Kopfschmerzen bereitet hat, um das mal gleich vorweg zu nehmen, weil wir da nicht wussten, wie wir da rangehen sollen, aber dazu gleich mehr. Und habe auch ein abgebrochenes Studium vorzuweisen, allerdings keins der Informatik, sondern der Medizin. Und habe da ein paar Jahre mit verbracht und habe aber nebenher eigentlich immer irgendwas mit IT oder in die Informatikschiene gemacht und bin dann letzten Endes bei einem Bachelor-Studiengang Informatik hingeblieben und mache jetzt meinen Master.
Wie schon gesagt, ihr seid ja beide aus Mannheim und da gibt es auch ein CCC.
Ein R-Verkreis.
Ein R-Verkreis. Wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, dann gründet man einen R-Verkreis.
So ist das, genau.
Für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was damit gemeint ist, das ist eine etwas merkwürdige Bezeichnung aus der CCC-Satzung für lokale Gruppen. Erfahrungsaustauschkreis, keine Ahnung, wer das mal in die Satzung geschrieben hat.
Aber ein schönes 80er-Wort, finde ich.
Ja, total. Nicht das einzige. Ja, bestimmt auch irgendeine Geschichte, die ich nicht kenne. Ja, so. Und was ist so? Was geht so in Mannheim?
Chaos macht Schule.
Ich meine, ich war jetzt noch nicht da. Gibt es da irgendwie einen Ort?
Ja, es gibt also in Mannheim schon ein bisschen Hackertum, sage ich es mal. Es gibt ein Hacker-Space, das Raum- und Zeitlabor, das ist auf dem Kongress vertreten. Ist halt so der klassische Hacker-Space mit Technik-Bastlereien und lokal ansässigen Gruppen. Und dann gibt es halt ein offizielles Organ des CCCs, also der FH-Kreis Mannheim. Und wir verfügen auch über Räumlichkeiten.
Also nochmal unabhängig davon. Das eine ist nicht in Verbindung mit dem anderen. Aber es gibt da die üblichen Überschneidungen.
Richtig, genau. Personalmäßig gleiche Überschneidungen und auch idee-mäßig. Ja, das passt ganz gut. Wir kommen so ein bisschen aus der Historie, aus einer WLAN interessierten Gruppe. So haben wir uns auch gefunden. 2001, ist richtig?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, das erste Mal getroffen haben wir uns 2003. Da war ich noch von unserem Forum-Eintrag von dir und da haben sich dann einige Leute in Mannheim gefunden, um mal offene WLANs suchen zu gehen und natürlich auch geschlossene.
Also wir kommen eigentlich im Prinzip aus dieser War-Driver-Szene und dann haben wir uns über Jahre hinweg, sag ich mal, den CCC-Themen immer mehr zugehörig gefühlt und dann haben wir gesagt, naja, warum machen wir dann nicht einfach, wenn wir schon CCC-Sachen machen, nicht einfach irgendwas in die Richtung Chaos-Treff und dann aus Chaos-Treff halt die natürliche Evolution mit Abspaltungen und Verkrachungen und so weiter, bis hin dann zum R-Verkreis. Ja und WLAN ist nach wie vor noch ein ganz starkes Thema bei uns, aber auch diverse andere Hardware-Bastlereien wie Lightbox ist vielleicht so gerade inspiriert, vielleicht auch ein Stück weit durch Blinking Lights, da was in der Hinsicht zu machen, aber auch da wir in der Realität...
Was ist das, Lightbox, was ist das nichts?
Bei uns auf der Wiki-Seite ein Eintrag dazu, ist ein aktives Projekt, das heißt, man nimmt so Ikea-Boxen und bastelt halt so ein bisschen Elektronik da rein. Genau richtig.
Alles klar, die auch offenbar auf dem Kongress standen.
Genau, das ist eine Münchner-Variante, wir machen was mit einem professionellen Bussystem, mit dem DMX-Bussystem, um da halt auch, sag ich mal, das Ganze gut skalierbar zu machen. Ja, und da wir eine recht kommunikative Gruppe eingestellt sind, also wir haben, sag ich mal, viele Leute, die einfach miteinander reden, nicht nur hacken, da hat sich halt dieses CMS-Thema da ganz gut angeboten und da arbeiten wir halt intensiv dran.
Wie kam es denn dann zu diesem eigentlichen Chaos macht Schule-Idee? Also ist das eigentlich in Mannheim geboren, der Gedanke?
Also es ist, glaube ich, in mehreren Airfars gleichzeitig geboren. Also wir hatten mal letztens bei ein paar Airfars und Chaos Trials nachgefragt und um die Kräfte ein bisschen zu sammeln, was Chaos macht Schule-Projekt angeht. Und es ist wohl so, dass unabhängig von uns im Jahr 2006 noch ein anderer Airfar, ich glaube Hamburg war das, den gleichen Namen auch für das Projekt irgendwie hatte und angefangen hatte und wir wussten nichts von denen, die wussten nichts von uns. Und wer da jetzt sozusagen der erste war, keine Ahnung.
Aber es war sehr interessant. Also es war ein interessanter Vorfeld mit demselben Namen.
Ja, ganz genau, gleicher Name. Und so ist es dann irgendwie 2006 entstanden. Relativ spontan, wir hatten einfach die Idee, an eine Schule zu gehen und einfach mal ein bisschen unser Wissen zu vermitteln, was wir so haben. Hatten irgendwie die Nase voll, uns gegenseitig immer zu erzählen, was wir vielleicht eh schon wissen, mehr oder minder. Und fanden die Idee gut, da vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen Nachwuchsarbeit machen zu können, indem man eben den Namen CCC ein bisschen bekannter werden lässt und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, was für das Image tut, des Hackers an sich, um einfach mal zu sagen, komm, wir sind nicht so böse, wir sind hier an Schulen, wir zeigen den Kids irgendwie, was für Sachen passieren können, wie man sich davor schützen kann. Und wir sind nicht die Bösen, um da einfach auch nochmal so ein bisschen Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten.
Ich denke, es war ganz wichtig, das Thema einfach aufzugreifen und zu sagen, wir sind die Guten im Prinzip. Weil ich denke, so das allgemeine Bild des Hackers in der nicht aufgeklärten Öffentlichkeit ist halt noch immer sehr, sehr differenziert und da ein Stück weit einfach das aufzugreifen.
Oder auch sehr undifferenziert, je nachdem, wie man es sieht.
Und vielleicht da schon, sag ich mal, den Kitties schon früh zu zeigen, dass wir eigentlich die Guten sind und nicht die Bösen. Und ich denke, da kann man umso früher mal anfängt, umso besser ist es dann später in ihrem Leben, das dann einfach so auch wiederzugeben, wie sie es mal richtig gelernt haben, unsere Meinung.
Ja, und heute auch immer noch, wenn wir die Gits heutzutage, wir fragen die immer, was ist für euch ein Hacker? Und am Anfang von der Veranstaltung. Und das sind immer die, die Bankkonten leer räumen und die, die Trojaner installieren. Das sind die Hacker. Und da eigentlich hat man da noch mehr Aufklärungsarbeit zu tun, als bei den eigentlichen Themen, weil das natürlich auch so eine Kernsache ist, die uns am Herzen liegt, irgendwie zu sagen, hier, da gibt es noch mehr. Also Hacker sein ist was sehr Kreatives und das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass ich irgendwo Trojaner auf einem Rechner installiere. Und das den Kids zu vermitteln und natürlich auch den Lehrern, die anwesend sind.
Und vielleicht auch den Eltern. Ja, damit zu tun, keinen Trojaner zu haben.
Genau, ganz richtig. Das sind auch wichtige Themen, die man da auch gleich mit abarbeiten kann, sag ich mal.
Ja, das ist immer so ein Abfallprodukt, was man halt bei solchen CMS-Veranstaltungen ganz gut anbringen kann, um auch vielleicht auch sich ein bisschen stückweit den Kitties auch zu öffnen. Die merken dann auf einmal so, oh, das sind eigentlich die Bösen und jetzt machen sie doch irgendwas Gutes. Und dann stößt man so ein Stück weit Denkprozess an und kann die dann ganz gut eigentlich abholen.
Wobei wir natürlich schon von unserem Image auch leben. Also wenn man da hingeht mit Anzug und Krawatte, ist das, glaube ich, eher kontraproduktiv, weil da hören die Kids einem eher nicht zu. Aber wenn man dann da in seiner üblichen schwarzen Montur mit Kapuzenpulli und dem Hacker-Image in Anfangsstrichen erstmal steht, dann hat man natürlich die volle Aufmerksamkeit erst mal. Und dann, damit muss man halt arbeiten, dass wenn man diese Aufmerksamkeit hat, dann darf man die Kids einfach nicht mehr loslassen. Und dann funktioniert das eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Bevor wir da vielleicht so ein bisschen in die Details, wie das so abläuft, frage ich jetzt halt immer noch, okay, jetzt habt ihr euch da so hingesetzt und habt gesagt, mich immer nur mit den anderen zu unterhalten, das ist langweilig. Wie kommt man dann so auf Schule? Ich meine jetzt irgendwie, dieses Ding in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen, aufklärerisch zu wirken und so, das ist ja so ein Wesenzug des CCC eigentlich von Anbeginn an. Wobei man eben diese Therapie der Gesellschaft, eigentlich haben wir eher mit der Tagesschau angefangen, als jetzt irgendwie in dem Sektor. Wow, der Gründer, der hat ja eigentlich auch immer dieses Thema gehabt und hat ja auch selber eigentlich so auch in der Fortbildung gearbeitet, in dem war dieses Thema schon immer wichtig, aber dass das jetzt, sagen wir mal, so über den ganzen Club verteilt, wirklich so die primäre Tätigkeit wäre, das war so zumindest bisher ja nicht unbedingt sichtbar. Was, ich meine, als ihr jetzt diese Idee hattet, was, ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt einfach zur Schule geht und sagt, guten Tag, wir sind der Chaos Computer Club, können wir jetzt mal den Unterricht übernehmen, wo seid ihr da hingegangen, was war da euer Ansatz?
Vielleicht muss man erstmal anfangen, warum gehen wir überhaupt an die Schule, oder wie ist die Idee gekommen, an die Schule zu gehen. Fakt ist, und so haben wir uns das eigentlich auch am Anfang gedacht, dass du ganz viel bewegen kannst bei den Kids noch. Also es ist nicht diese Lost Generation, die irgendwie nur Pornos guckt und die Eltern nicht wissen, was Sache ist und es wird alles schlecht und böse und wir werden alle sterben, sondern wir selber merken, dass man da tatsächlich, wenn die Kids aus so einer Veranstaltung rausgehen, wirklich was mitnehmen. Nicht alle, logischerweise kriegt man nie alle, aber man kann da was bewegen und das ist genau die Generation, die ihren Kids irgendwann mal...
Aber das wusstet ihr ja vorher nicht. Das ist im Prinzip eine Erfahrung, die...
Also wir konnten uns schon irgendwie denken, dass du bei Kids irgendwie mehr bewirken kannst, als bei irgendwelchen 50-Jährigen, die ihr schon denken, sie wissen, wie der Hase läuft. Und wenn man da halt an SIP-Klässler rangeht oder so, dann kann man die noch ein bisschen, wie sagt man das, so schön formen. Und ich glaube, dass das einfach so dieser Multiplikator-Effekt ist. Und davon sind wir auch ausgegangen, dass wenn wir an eine Schule gehen, dass wir da quasi sehr viel mehr bewirken können, auch für die Zukunft, als wenn wir da jetzt Veranstaltungen für Senioren machen. Ich sage jetzt mal das krasse Gegenbeispiel.
Und war das jetzt auch so ein Thema, dass man das ja auch nicht nur den Medien, auch sagen wir mal so Gesprächen, gibt ja dann auch diese ganzen Stereotypen, so das Internet, das ist ja irgendwie schädlich und Internet-Sucht und Ballerspiele, lalala und das Kind hängt nur vom Computer und so. Ist das irgendwie auch jetzt ein Anreiz gewesen, darüber nachzudenken?
Vielleicht stimmt das ja auch. Natürlich ist diese Aufklärungsarbeit war natürlich wichtig, aber worüber wir den Einstieg erst mal gefunden haben, ist wir wollten eigentlich erst mal über die Gefahren sozusagen aufklären. Also was bedeutet es eigentlich, eine E-Mail zu verschicken? Wer könnte die alles lesen? Kann man die überhaupt lesen? Kann man die abfangen? Wie ist das mit Passwörtern? Was macht ein sicheres Passwort aus? Diese Geschichten standen am Anfang, bei unseren ersten Veranstaltungen im Vordergrund. Und darüber hinaus hat sich dann herauskristallisiert, was eigentlich wirklich die Punkte sind, die die Kids interessiert, die auch viel wichtiger sind. Also da gibt es ein paar Sachen, die sind einfach unwichtig und redundant und machen keinen Sinn, wenn man da eine Stunde vor Kindern irgendwie was referiert, dass man denen das erzählt, weil die nehmen da nichts mit sozusagen. Und das ist aber schon wieder der Erfahrungsschatz, den wir haben.
Genau, also vielleicht mal ganz kurz mal zu deiner ursprünglichen Frage zurückzukommen, wie war uns das Ganze oder wie ist das Ganze entstanden? Ich kann mich noch an ein Gespräch zwischen uns beiden erinnern. Florian, als wir irgendwann da gesessen haben und sagen, naja, gut, jetzt sind wir hier, jetzt machen wir das und das und das. Und wie machen wir da jetzt weiter? Und ich glaube, da war so ein paar Ideen, naja, mit diesen Vorträgen, die wir innerhalb des Clubs machen. Wir treffen uns da alle 14 Tage zunehmend zu einem Vortrag und haben gesagt, okay, da erreichen wir halt nur unsere Peer-Group und wir wollten halt irgendwie aus dieser Peer-Group rauskommen und sagen, okay, meistens kommen eh die gleichen Leute und mal hier plus minus ein paar, aber wir wollen irgendwie das Ganze auch ein bisschen weiter rausbringen und uns in den Sektor bewegen, wo vielleicht nicht unbedingt alles CCC Leute sind oder technikinteressierte Leute. Und es kam doch, glaube ich, damals aus deinem Informatik-Lehrer, deiner ehemaligen Schule. Genau, mit denen hat es doch mal ein Gespräch gehabt.
Genau, also Connections sind natürlich wichtig, weil sowas, wenn man den Einstieg finden muss. Und da war das halt so, dass man da, wenn man so was vorhat, so mal tippt nebenbei, dann idealerweise wendet man sich erstmal an eine Schule, auf der man selber war, wo man bekannt ist, möglicherweise mit einem guten Ruf auch. Und geht dann da, tritt da einfach mal die Lehrer ran. In der Regel ist das relativ problemlos. Die sind da extrem dankbar, dass jemand kommt und dieses Thema behandeln möchte.
Also du bist an deine alte Schule gegangen, klar. Weil da hast du einen Einstieg, da kannst du die Lehrer noch.
Genau. Und man kennt auch die Schule so ein bisschen.
Welches Fach? Ich meine, wo bist du da aufgeschlagen? Bist du irgendwie in der Schulleitung oder hast du da irgendwie gleich ein Fach?
2005 oder 2006, als wir da an die Schule drangegangen sind, gab es einen wissenschaftlichen Zug sozusagen in der Oberstufe. Und die hatten auch irgendwas mit IT, keine Ahnung, so Computer im weitesten Sinne. Mussten die irgendwie in ein Fach belegen. Das war aber nur eine Stunde die Woche, also irgendwas ganz, ganz kleines.
Also Oberstufe, wir reden vom Gymnasium.
Genau, ganz genau. Und genau, dann an den Informatik-Lehrer sozusagen herangetreten. Beziehungsweise ich hatte noch ein paar alte Kontakte, habe die angeschrieben und die meinten, ja, hier Informatik-Lehrer wäre da das Beste, vielleicht für den wissenschaftlichen Zug. Und so hat dann das eine und das andere gegeben. Ich habe mich mit den Lehrern unterhalten, beziehungsweise mit dem zuständigen Lehrer, der fand das auch toll, hat sich dann eingesetzt bei der Schulleitung für uns. Und dann war das eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem, da reinzukommen.
Was war jetzt das Angebot quasi?
Dass wir mal zwei Unterrichtsstunden übernehmen und einfach mal ins Blaue hinaus, also er wollte da auch im Vorfeld nicht so wirklich genau wissen, um was geht's. Wir haben ihm halt gesagt, Sicherheit im Internet, Sicherheit im Netz, Datenschutz, diese Sachen werden wir irgendwie abhandeln und das hat auch schon gereicht, um irgendwie den Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen. Und das hat dann auch super geklappt.
Weil die einfach generell eigentlich dankbar sind, wenn überhaupt irgendjemand was kommt.
Genau, vor allem für dieses Thema. Also das ist halt, erstmal ist es für die Kids eine Abwechslung, wenn die da mal andere Leute sehen, auch zu dem Thema. Und die sind halt wirklich dankbar, dass jemand dieses Thema kompetent behandeln kann. Weil sie sich da selber halt auch unsicher fühlen. Das ist halt einfach faktisch so.
Ich denke auch, dass das bei den Kindern auch ganz anders ankommt. Wenn halt jetzt jemand anderes als der Lehrer vorne steht und sagt, hier das Intern ist böse oder das Intern ist gut. Sondern das ist einfach mal, wie soll ich sagen, eine willkommene Abwechslung. Und wenn sie noch irgendwelche Leute haben, wo sie einen Eindruck erwecken, das sind Profis, dann ist das, glaube ich, ein ganz guter Einstieg. Und dann hat man, glaube ich, die Lehrer auf so eine gewisse Sicherheit. Also es ist nicht irgendwie ein Dahergelaufener, der halt irgendwie sagt, naja, ich kann einen PC ausschalten, erzähle euch heute was übers Internet. Sondern dass halt auch da eine gewisse seriöse Kompetenz einfach dann vorhanden ist.
Also ich meine, von welchem Alter, von welchem Jahrgang reden wir jetzt eigentlich?
Also angefangen, unser erstes Chaos macht Schule war eine 10. Klasse, meine ich, oder eine 11.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, eine 11.
Klasse. Und das ist viel zu spät, weil die denken wirklich, sie wüssten alles. Und da kommt man relativ schwer dran noch. Also die lehnen sich dann eher zurück und denken, ja, ist ja alles klar und weiß ich, weiß ich, weiß ich. Und so bei uns, es ist natürlich immer so eine Frage des Vortragsstils und wie man selber an die Sache rangeht. Einen richtigen Zeitpunkt gibt es eigentlich nicht. Es gibt bloß den Zeitpunkt, der viel zu spät ist. Und für uns ist kristallisiert sich heraus, dass die Art und Weise, wie wir an so eine Veranstaltung rangehen, wie wir arbeiten, das, was wir versuchen zu vermitteln, ideal ist für siebte Klasse. Also in der siebten Klasse ist das, was wir tun eigentlich am besten. Weil die auf der einen Seite schon so weit sind, dass sie Dinge und Zusammenhänge gut verstehen können, dass sie auch das, was wir sozusagen als Hintergrundinformation so mitgeben, ein bisschen einordnen können. Aber die Nase noch nicht so hoch tragen, dass sie sich noch nichts sagen lassen. Sondern die lassen sich schon noch so ein bisschen erzählen, wenn ihr das tut, dann passiert das. Und dann nehmen die das auch mal so hin und akzeptieren das.
Siebte Klasse, wie alt sind die dann?
Wie alt sind die?
13, 14, kann das sein?
Also der Punkt ist natürlich auch der, dass mit unserem Vortragsstil natürlich man schon ein bisschen Voraussetzungen haben muss. Das heißt, die müssen schon immer irgendwie vom Grüner gesessen haben. Darum ist halt so vierte Klasse oder dritte Klasse vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig. Und da wir einen starken oder einen starken Fokus auf diese ganzen sozialen Netze und Medien haben, müssen die ja schon da irgendwo aktiv sein. Und ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass halt die meisten Viertklässler, dass sie da schon irgendwie einen PC haben, über den sie frei verfügen können oder halt irgendwie betreut verfügen können und die halt dann schon irgendwo an so einer Community schon teilgenommen haben. Und dementsprechend ist das, glaube ich, ganz gut, wenn die so in der fünften Klasse da hinkommen und merken, oh, es gibt halt da so ein Portal, wo die ganzen Schüler auch sind, um so ein bisschen ihre soziale Kompetenz aufzubauen. Und dann sind die halt schon mal ein Jahr da. Das heißt, die haben da schon mal ein Jahr auch damit gearbeitet. Und dann, wenn man im Folgejahr kommt, dann kann man die auch da abholen. Dann wissen die halt auch schon, um was es geht. Die kennen diese ganzen Portale. Also es bringt ja jetzt nichts da, eine Einführung zu machen. Wie bediene ich halt so ein Social Network? Es geht ja auch darum, da die Leute darauf hinzuweisen.
Das Problem ist ja auch so ein bisschen, was möchte man tun, wenn man eher präventiv arbeiten möchte. Es ist natürlich schlecht, wenn die alle schon, sag ich mal, ihre Daten verloren haben, in Anführungsstrichen. Wenn man einfach nur aufklären möchte, es ist im Prinzip egal, wann man da an die Sache rangeht. Wenn man präventiv tätig sein möchte, dann muss man die irgendwo sechste, siebte abfangen. Sechste Klasse sind die halt so, dass sie gerade im Moment, also das ändert sich natürlich auch. Also ich glaube, in zwei Jahren sieht die Sache auch wieder ganz anders aus. Da werden wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr Sechstklässler bei Facebook sein, als es momentan ist. Momentan ist unsere Erfahrung, dass wenn man in der siebten Klasse fragt, wer es bei Facebook sind, das alle. Und wenn man in der sechsten Klasse fragt, dann sind das die Hälfte, wenn überhaupt. Also da ist gerade so dieser Bruch, wo die anfangen, damit zu arbeiten. Das ist von einem Jahr auf den anderen sozusagen. Die machen da einen krassen Entwicklungsschritt auch und sind von sechster auf siebte Klasse.
Klar, wenn die Freunde da sind, dann...
Genau, das zieht halt....
wie das eben funktioniert. Okay, und wie war es beim ersten Mal? Du hast ja schon gesagt, das war jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so...
Also eigentlich war es, im Endeffekt war es ein absoluter Erfolg eigentlich. Der Lehrer war total begeistert. Wir haben bloß selber für uns jetzt aus der Perspektive, wo wir sie jetzt haben, sieht man halt, dass man schon so ein paar krasse Fehler gemacht hat. Also wir waren zum Beispiel viel zu technisch.
Genau, also wir haben die Kids jetzt ein bisschen was über RFCs erzählt und so. Da haben wir gemerkt, okay, das bringt nichts. Die würden nicht wissen wie E-Mail, auf was im RFC das basiert.
Oder wie iSecure, TCPIP und mit Sniffen, was ist ein Sniffer, bla, bla, bla. Also interessiert die das schon.
Ja, da rächt sich die Nerdperspektive.
Richtig, ganz genau. Und wir hatten eigentlich versucht, diesen Fehler nicht zu machen, weil wir damit ja schon gerechnet haben, man muss die Kids irgendwie abholen. Aber im Endeffekt haben wir dann doch schon so ein paar Fehler gemacht, wo wir einfach gemerkt haben, die lehnen sich dann zurück. Und dann geht es da rein, da raus und im Endeffekt.
Vor allem ist es sowas auch viel zu aufwendig, wenn man so eine Unterrichtsstunde zu gestalten hat und dann anfängt, irgendwie mit Sniffen und Erklären und Machen und Tun. Das heißt, man kann die eigentlichen Inhalte gar nicht transportieren, weil eigentlich 30 Prozent drauf geht für Begriffserklärung und guckt mal da und Aufbau. Und wir brauchen noch einen Freiwilligen hier und tippt mal da was ein und jetzt kommt hier was raus. Oh, nee, doch nicht. Wir müssen das noch mal machen. Mir verblämmt man damit zu viel Zeit. Man muss das so relativ kurz und knackig machen. Der Vorteil war, wir haben, glaube ich, ganz gut reflektiert das erste Mal. Also wir waren ganz gut selbstkritisch. Und trotz der Bestätigung des Lehrers, dass das gut war, haben wir uns trotzdem, glaube ich, mal hingesetzt und haben gesagt, okay, ist das wirklich das, was wir den Kiddies in einer Stunde oder eineinhalb Stunden erklären wollen, wie irgendwie RFC-Protokolle oder erklärt sind?
Also wir hatten, glaube ich, auch jemanden, der nur mitgeschrieben hat die ganze Zeit sogar. Also so richtig strebermäßig waren wir und geguckt hat, welche Fragen werden wann gestellt, wann schalten die Kids ab, wann ist es irgendwie zu langatmig und so.
Also ihr hattet noch einen dritten Mann in der Klasse, oder was?
Wir waren, im Prinzip waren wir, glaube ich, zu sechst oder so da im Endeffekt. Genau, richtig, man in Black. Also schön alles distributed. Das heißt, jeder hatte irgendwie so seinen Teil, den er irgendwie vorbereitet hat, damit es nicht auf einer Schulter lastet, sozusagen. Und dann haben wir einfach mal geguckt, haben das hintereinander geschmissen, sozusagen, haben versucht, rauszufinden, was funktioniert eigentlich.
Und ein anderer hat einfach beobachtet und ein Protokoll geschrieben.
Ganz genau. Und daraus haben wir dann relativ schnell gemerkt, was geht und was geht nicht. Auch das Feedback dann sozusagen, das Feedback von den Schülern war sehr positiv. Natürlich, was sollen die anderen sagen, wenn da irgendwie Leute kommen und mal den Unterricht etwas anders gestalten. Also das ist klar, dass da positives Feedback kommt. Der Lehrer war auch sehr begeistert und wir sind auch nach wie vor immer noch an der Schule. Also Jahre später auch noch werden wir immer noch eingeladen. Das spricht, glaube ich, für das Projekt.
Aber was hat die Manöverkritik dann gebracht? Also was sollst du rausfliegen?
Genau. Also wir hatten relativ viele Demos, die in die Richtung Security gegangen sind. Wie Peter schon gesagt hat, Sniffing und so weiter, Passwörter, Klartext, wie sieht es verschlüsselt aus und so weiter. Und das ist den Kids total egal. Also das finden die zwar toll, wenn die das sehen, aber im Endeffekt nehmen die da nichts mit. Das heißt, diese ganzen Demos sind bis auf eine einzige Security-Demo sozusagen rausgeflogen. Die einzige Security-Demo, die wir am Anfang immer noch machen, um da nochmal so ein bisschen unseren Status als Hacker, sag ich mal, ein bisschen zu unterfüttern, ist, dass wir, wir haben eine VM-Ware laufen mit Windows drauf und da schmeißen wir Rainbow-Tables drauf. Und dann kommen die Kids, sechs Kids, holen wir nach vorne. Drei davon geben ein starkes Passwort ein, das denken sie sich dann aus. Wir erklären dann parallel, was macht ein gutes und was macht ein schwaches Passwort aus. Und drei davon geben ein schwaches Passwort ein. Und dann jagen wir da unsere Rainbow-Tables drüber und versuchen eben, möglichst nur die schwachen Passwörter zu knacken, was auch schon schiefgegangen ist. Und dann hatten wir die falschen Rainbow-Tables und hatten irgendwie das komplette Charset von Rainbow-Tables und hatten dann alle Passwörter auf einmal klar Text. Da ist der Lerneffekt dann natürlich nicht so groß. Aber in der Regel klappt das dann. Und dann sehen die Kids sozusagen direkt, was macht ein starkes, was macht ein gutes Passwort aus. Und hier sieht es im Endeffekt. Und das finden wir alle eigentlich immer ganz toll. Und das ist eigentlich die einzige Demo, die wirklich so security-mäßig übrig geblieben ist. Wir haben noch eine zweite Demo.
Das hat ja schon so ein bisschen was von Zauberer. Da kommt man dann wieder so hin, stellt sich hin und sagt, ja hier, deswegen machen wir das grundsätzlich am Anfang. Wie lange dauert das mit den Rainbow Tables?
Das kann man schon mal im Hintergrund laufen. Das ist gut.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wann kommt das Ergebnis dann?
Ich denke mal, fünf Minuten brauchen es wirklich lang. Das Schöne ist, es geht ja nicht um diesen Effekt Rainbow Tables oder Knacken, es geht halt darum, die machen was. Die sind ein bisschen eingebunden, die ganze Geschichte. Man hat denen vorher ein bisschen Wissen über Passwörter vermittelt. Die nehmen dieses Wissen, was ganz frisch ist, praktisch mit sich mit, setzen sich an diesen PC, geben ihr Passwort ein und kriegen dann anschließend gezeigt, ok, bestätigt, habe ich es kapiert oder habe ich es nicht kapiert. Und das ist glaube ich der beste Lernen-Fakt, was die eigentlich da mitnehmen.
Ja genau, also die geben dann teilweise halt auch Passwörter ein, wo sie denken, das ist ein starkes Passwort. Und im Endeffekt fliegt es ihnen halt um die Ohren. Und dann kann man direkt nochmal sagen, hier guck mal, du solltest doch eigentlich ein starkes Passwort eingeben.
Und sitzt da nicht manchmal noch so ein pfiffiger Nerd in der Runde, der dann sagt, naja, ich habe das ja in eurem Computer eingegeben. Das konnte der ja direkt an der Tatsache, dass du abstreifst.
Interessanterweise nicht. Aber ich hoffe auch, dass niemand unserer zukünftigen Schüler, wo wir hingehen, in diesem Podcast wäre. Interessanterweise kommt diese Frage nie. Zumal wir sogar den Extremfall mal hatten, dass die Leute sich ihr starkes Passwort nicht merken konnten und dann haben sie es auf einen Zettel geschrieben. Man muss es ja zweimal eingeben. Der Zettel lag dann da und wir haben halt den Zettel gesehen. Aber im Endeffekt glauben die einem das. Man profitiert einfach von diesem Image, dass die nicht davon ausgehen, man bescheißt die da jetzt, sondern die denken wirklich, beziehungsweise...
Die denken, das wäre alles wahr.
Aber zu deinem Punkt zurückzukommen, mit dem Eingeben. Klar, das kann man natürlich dann aufnehmen und nochmal zwei, drei Sätze zu sagen. Okay, nach dem Motto, geben die dein Passwort ein, wo du nicht weißt, dass es ein sicheres Environment ist. Und zum Zweiten, glaube ich, kriegt man die so ein bisschen vertrauensmäßig, weil die ihr Passwort selbst eingeben. Ich glaube, da kommt dann die Frage nicht so, weil du denkst, naja, sie geben es selbst ein, würden sie uns das jetzt sagen und wir würden es eintippen, würden sie sagen, ja, das habe ich eh vorher schon gewusst. Aber so hat man auch den Bonus, dass sie es selbst eingeben und dementsprechend halt das Gefühl haben, okay, wir haben es halt nicht gesehen.
Naja, also wie er schon meint, zu technisch werden hilft auch nicht, wenn man jetzt sagt, das Kapitel Keylogger aufmacht. Genau.
Eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, weil ich das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Tipp, vielleicht auch mal so nach draußen. Die zweite Security-Demo, die wir sozusagen machen, und zwar erklären wir, wie funktioniert verschlüsselte und unverschlüsselte Kommunikation, quasi wie funktioniert das Internet. Und da holen wir immer drei Freiwillige nach vorne, die lassen wir in der Reihe aufstellen und dann hat sozusagen der eine eine Postkarte in der Hand und auf dieser Postkarte steht halt irgendein Text und wir versuchen dann über diese Postkarte zu vermitteln. Diese Postkarte wird jetzt quasi über das Internet, was dann die Zwischenleute sind, die da in der Reihe stehen, weitergetragen, bis sie am Empfänger ankommt. Und der schöne Effekt, den man dann immer hat, ist, dass der erste, der die Postkarte in die Hand nimmt, direkt anfängt zu lesen. Also der liest die Postkarte. Und wenn man den Kids vorher erklärt hat, das sind die Knoten im Internet, sozusagen die Knotenpunkte, die es gibt.
Weil sie machen das einfach automatisch.
Ganz genau. Und dann muss man quasi, wenn der erste diese Postkarte in die Hand nimmt, muss man einfach nur das Auditorium fragen, was fällt euch gerade auf? Oder was fällt euch jetzt auf? Was guckt hin? Und dann kommt sofort die Wortmeldung auch. Ah, der liest die ja. Der hat die gelesen. Und dann hat man sie sofort. Und kann daraufhin sozusagen alles, was ihr kommuniziert, alles, was ihr tut, so funktioniert.
Und was ist dann das Sinnbild für die Verschlüsselten? Ist das ein Entbriefaumschlag?
Also wir machen dann den Vergleich natürlich. Warum haben wir jetzt hier eine Postkarte genommen und keinen Brief? Und dann ist klar, die Antwort ja, Brief ist ja ein, da kann man nicht. Postgeheimnisse und so, das darf man nicht auch machen. Und wir verschicken dann einfach noch mal eine zweite Postkarte, wo wir dann ausgedruckt PGP-Text draufhaben und dann den Betreffen natürlich noch unverschlüsselt drauf schreiben, weil wir ja Wert legen, dass das alles korrekt ist. Und genau, lassen die dann noch mal durchgehen und dann sehen die Kids halt irgendwie nur Datenmüll. Versuchen das dann auch zu Entschlüsse, was sehr lustig ist. Also da kann man dann auch wieder sagen, sozusagen hier, ja, das dauert jetzt sehr viel länger, bis da jemand mal einen Durchblick hat und genau.
Das Schöne ist halt, wir fragen halt meistens immer auch die Kids, die nicht nur vorne stehen, sondern auch im Publikum sitzen. Was fällt euch auf oder was ist euch aufgefallen? Deshalb, wir wollen ja auch ein bisschen Input von denen haben. Wir wollen nicht nur dastehen und erklären, hier passiert das und das, sondern wir fragen halt gezielt einfach mal, sag mal, wie ist denn euer Eindruck, was ist da passiert? Und ich finde, das ist ganz wichtig, um auch die Kiddies auch ein bisschen bei Laune zu halten oder sich dafür zu interessieren, nicht dass die alle abschalten. Das ist immer ganz gut, dass auch ihre eigenen Leute sozusagen vorne stehen. Das heißt, das ist ein ganz ganz anderer Effekt. Weil, zum Beispiel jetzt mal eine Menschenkette aus vier Nerds da irgendwie aufbauen, und dann denken sie sich, na gut, okay. Aber so hat man halt einen ganz ganz guten Effekt da nochmal dabei.
Seid ihr denn jetzt mittlerweile auch immer da zu viert oder zu fünft, oder habt ihr das ein bisschen eingedanscht?
Minimal sind es immer zwei eigentlich. Also weil einer, wir machen es meistens so, dass wir eine Demo haben auf der linken Seite irgendwie mit einem Beamer und einen separaten Beamer nochmal für einen Powerpoint. Und da ist es halt einfach ungeschickt, wenn dann einer hin und her rennen muss. Also wir sind meistens immer zu zweit. Der Vorteil ist, wenn man zu viert da auch, wir sind da auch manchmal zu fünft, dann kann man das irgendwie für einen größeren Rahmen auch so schön gestalten, dass man so ein kleines Hackcenter quasi einrichtet, dass man an der Bühne irgendwie links so einen Tisch hinstellt, wo dann die drei Kappen mit fünf Laptops sitzen oder so. Und das ist auch nochmal so, ich sage mal, dem Image zuträglich, ja, für den Beginn der Veranstaltung. Und das sind dann die Leute, die die Technik sozusagen übernehmen, die dann auch mit den Freiwilligen arbeiten und die nach vorne holen und dann denen leise erklären, was ist ein sicheres, was ist ein starkes Passwort, während dann der Referent, sage ich mal, vorne steht und dem Auditorium erklärt, was jetzt passiert.
Mal dadurch einen ganz guten Fluss hat sich herausgestellt, weil wenn man da nur jetzt alleine wäre mit den ganzen Demos, da geht man immer raus aus der ganzen Geschichte, muss halt erst was erklären, die Programme starten, sich einloggen, darauf achten, dass sie nicht unbedingt die Passwörter sehen. Und ja, und so ist es halt bedeutend einfacher für den Vortragenden, der kann auch da mal eine Sekunde in sich gehen, mal gucken, okay, wie reagieren die restlichen Leute und was passiert denn gerade. Das ist, glaube ich, auch für die, für uns selbst als Milestone eigentlich immer ganz gut gesetzt, um einfach mal zu gucken, okay, muss ich vielleicht irgendein Thema doch jetzt intensiver betrachten oder vielleicht noch was ansprechen oder einfach jetzt mal einen Raum für Fragen lassen.
Und dem kommt auch zugute, dass wir sozusagen versuchen, eigentlich eher mit den Kids zu arbeiten. Also wir wollen keinen Vortrag halten eigentlich. Also unsere Show in Anführungsstrichen lebt davon, dass die Kids auch mal ein bisschen abschweifen und in eine andere Richtung gehen, weil dann entsteht eine Diskussion fast schon. Dann entstehen Fragen, spontane Fragen, auf die wieder Fragen kommen, weil die wieder Fragen aufwerfen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann lebt die ganze Sache. Und das ist eigentlich so das Beste, was passieren kann.
Also der Zeitrahmen ist wahrscheinlich so 3 Viertelstunde, oder?
Das kommt drauf an. Also normalerweise den Standard-Klassik-Vortrag, den wir sozusagen machen, der beläuft sich so im Rahmen von einer Stunde, Stunde, zehn Minuten ungefähr.
Also Doppelstunde plus anschließend Fragerunde, oder?
Doppelstunde wären 90 Minuten, also 2 mal 45. Also und darunter ist es eigentlich nicht sinnvoll, weil wir dann durchhetzen müssen, das macht keinen Sinn.
Sind denn jetzt Doppelstunden dann auch immer so verfügbar?
Eigentlich schon, ja. Also wenn wir sagen, wir kommen und wir machen das, dann ist eigentlich auch in der Regel wie lange und wann und wie. Und dann sagt man, wir würden eine Doppelstunde...
Bauen die dann den Stundenplan um, oder ist das einfach so?
Entweder bauen die den Stundenplan um, oder sie legen es halt dahin, wo es passt.
Genau, also meistens ist ja auch Informatik so die klassische Doppelstunde. Also da passt es meistens.
Wir machen auch viel extern. Ist das so? Ich hatte auch keine Informatik. Bei mir gab es das noch nicht tatsächlich. Aber ich glaube, normalerweise, oder sie räumen irgendwie eine letzte Stunde frei oder so und hängen dann noch eine dran. Also das passt.
Oder statt Sport mal einfach dann...
Was wir auch häufig machen, ist an...
Heute Gedankensport.
Und was wir häufig auch machen, ist quasi einen externen Anbieter an fünf Strichen einzuschalten. Zum Beispiel irgendein Stadthaus, ein Jugendhaus oder so, die dann einfach sagen, die Schulen anschreibt und sagt, hier schickt mal zwei, drei Klassen und dann haben wir tolle Vorträge. Wobei man da auch wieder aufpassen muss. Also eine Klasse ist natürlich top, weil man mit denen schön arbeiten kann und genau weiß, wer ist irgendwie wer, charaktertechnisch auch. Und sobald man da, also ich glaube, so das Maximum, was wirklich geht, wo man noch kommunikativ arbeiten kann, sind irgendwie so 50, 60 Kids. Und dann wird es aber schon echt schwer.
Ja, vor allem kommt auf einmal, wie diszipliniert die ganzen sind.
Wie groß sind die Klassen, die er auf dir üblicherweise trifft?
Eine Klasse von 20 bis 25 Leute. Manchmal auch, das kommt auf die Schule drauf an.
Manchmal legen sie auch so zwei Klassen zusammen, dann sind es halt mal knapp 30 oder so. Ja, das geht also.
Also quasi mehr als zwei Klassen zusammen. Ist schwierig.
Genau. Geht gerade noch, aber ist schwierig.
Also wir merken halt für unseren, wie gesagt, unser Vortrag ist mehr so Workshop-Charakter. Da brauchen wir auch so ein bisschen Interaktion. Das heißt, wenn dann halt an 30 Fragen statt 5 kommen, dann kommen wir natürlich auch zeitlich ein bisschen in die Bridulie. Das Schöne ist natürlich an diesen ganzen, diesen Workshop nenne ich es eigentlich, den wir da machen, dass wir eigentlich auch genug Material haben, auch diese Fragen zu befriedigen. Mal sehen ja natürlich oft, dass es in eine bestimmte Richtung einfach geht, die sind interessiert, die wollen mehr Sachen wissen. Und dann hatten natürlich auch noch ein paar Extra-Slides dabei, wo man sagen kann, okay, wir lassen vielleicht ein Thema ein bisschen hinten runterfallen und sind dann so dynamisch, dass wir sagen können, okay, wir gehen halt jetzt gezielt drauf ein, weil sich einfach jetzt die Fragerunde dahin entwickelt hat.
Häufig ist es auch so, dass es an der Schule vielleicht auch ein Vorfall gegeben hat zu irgendeinem Problem und deswegen da gerade extrem viel Fragen und Bedarf ist. Und dann machen wir das auch spontan.
Also auf der einen Seite habt ihr quasi so ein Standard-Einstiegsvortrag, aber es gibt auch darauf aufbauend noch weitere Sachen oder es kann auch mal das und mal das sein, je nachdem, was gefragt ist.
Genau, also wir haben so ein Standard-Repertoire momentan halt mit Kernpunkt Social Media und alles, was dazugehört, aber wir haben auch Zusätze, sag ich mal. Wir sind ja nicht nur einmalig an Schulen, sondern wir machen auch im Rahmen der Medien-Scouts auch mehrere Veranstaltungen in einem Schuljahr an Schulen. Da kann man nicht fünfmal das gleiche erzählen.
Was ist das im Rahmen der Medien-Scouts?
Vielleicht soll man das ein bisschen ausholen jetzt oder? Ja, genau. Also es gibt eine Kooperation in Mannheim, das nennt sich Netzwerk Neue Medien. Da sind halt verschiedene Institutionen dabei. Also da ist halt irgendwie die Stadt dabei, da ist Stadtjugend drin, die Polizei, Pro Familia, Caretas, Suchtberatungsstellen, da ist dabei Jugendämter, da ist dabei was es noch alles dabei ist. Und da gibt es dann so eine sehr, sehr wichtige Geschichte zum Thema Polizei. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist es halt, man hat gemerkt, es gibt aus verschiedenen Institutionen, die machen im Prinzip alles gleiche. Klar, die Polizei stellt sich halt irgendwie hin und sagt, das Internet ist böse, downloaden ist halt irgendwie scheiße und so. Und da stellt sich dann die Suchtberatung hin und sagt, naja, wenn ihr mehr als vier Stunden im Internet seid, seid ihr von süchtig oder gefährdet. Dann kommen halt irgendwie pro Familie und sagen, naja, die Kitties sitzen den ganzen Tag vom PC, ihr redet gar nicht mehr mit euren Kitties.
Ja, und sie gucken vor allem YouPorn.
Und dann sitzen halt irgendwie die Jugendämter oder die Jugendhäuser auch da und sagen, naja, die Kitties kommen nicht mehr zu uns, weil sie den ganzen Tag im Internet surfen. Und dementsprechend hat man gemerkt, okay, es gibt halt da irgendwie eine gemeinsame Basis, einen gemeinsamen Bildungsauftrag schon fast. Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, man gründet halt so eine Vereinigung in Mannheim.
Das ist aber auch so ein bisschen so eine glashalbvoll, glashalb leer Geschichte.
In dem Fall geht das eigentlich relativ gut. Es gibt so ein paar Leute in diesem Netzwerk, also allen voran, tut mir leid, dass ich das sagen muss, aber es ist die Polizei und die Jugendämter, die da ganz, ganz, ganz viel anstoßen und sehr, sehr effektive und tolle Sachen machen. Das muss man wirklich mal sagen.
Man muss vielleicht sagen, aus diesen ganzen Entities, die klingen alle ganz furchtbar, aber es gibt halt diese Leute, die dieses Projekt machen, die sind vom Mindset her relativ gleich. Also man merkt es, er ist halt Polizist vom Beruf, aber...
Hätte auch beim CCC entgegen.
Genau, richtig, ganz genau. Und das ist halt das Positive an der ganzen Geschichte. Darum gucken wir da auch relativ locker hin, wenn man sonst sagt, okay, Martin Cooper hat zu mit der Polizei, naja, ob das dann immer so gut ist.
Also Medienscouts, das ist jetzt quasi ein Programm von der Stadt, oder ist das einfach so untereinander?
Also es gab mal in Rheinland-Pfalz, mein ich wäre das gewesen, ein ähnliches Projekt, was irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, im Sande verlaufen ist. Und in Mannheim, also es ging erst mal nur um die Stadt Mannheim jetzt, kam dann die Idee auf sowas einfach auf regionaler Ebene in Mannheim zu machen. Die Initiative ging dann von der Kriminalprävention aus, von der Polizeiebene und von den Jugendämtern. Und die haben gesagt, wir möchten dieses Medien-Scout-Projekt irgendwie einführen. Und das heißt im Prinzip, dass die an Schulen gehen zu kritischen Themen, sich die neun Klessler, zehn Klessler schnappen, die Schulen über ein ganzes Schuljahr hinweg und die dann im nächsten Jahr in die fünften und sechsten Klassen gehen und so Teach the Teacher-mäßig dann die Kids selbst belehren und den erzählten Vorträge halten, in die Klassen gehen. Und das ist sozusagen so dieses Konzept, was hinter den Medienscouts steht. Multiplikatoren ausbilden, die dann die Arbeit übernehmen.
Genau, man hat gedacht, wir können uns doch nicht die nächsten 20 Jahre in allen Schulen, die es in Mannheim gibt, hinstellen, weil wir es einfach kapazitätsmäßig nicht schaffen können. Und es ist einfach am glaubwürdigsten, wenn es einer aus den eigenen Reihen ist. Also nach dem Motto, früher gab es halt in der Klasse ein Klassensprecher und ein Streitschlichter und keine Ahnung, so ein Vertrauensschüler. Und darum wollte man das Ganze ergänzen, um halt so einen Medien-Scout, der halt da medienkompetent ist, den man halt vielleicht als erstes ansprechen kann, wenn man nicht direkt zum Lehrer rennen möchte oder zu seinem Mitschüler, der so ein Klassenerd, der einfach weiß, okay, da ist es...
Interessanterweise sind das gar nicht, wenn du dir mal anguckst, wer eigentlich diese Medien-Scout-Ausbildung absolviert, sind das interessanterweise gar nicht die Nerds, sondern das sind echt, ich hätte fast gesagt, die normalen Kinder.
Ich glaube, als Medien-Scout brauchst du auch so eine gewisse soziale Kompetenz und das ist vielleicht bei Nerds nicht immer so gegeben.
Ja, das stimmt, das kann sein.
Genau, und dementsprechend sind es halt eher die sozial kompetenten Leute, aber auch die, sag ich mal, gefährdeten Leute. Also ich kann mich an eine Klasse erinnern, da gibt es zum Beispiel jemand, der war Internetspiele süchtig und das ist natürlich das Beste, was du nehmen kannst, weil der ist glaubwürdig auch den anderen Leuten gegenüber.
Er weiß von was er redet.
Genau. Und das ist halt natürlich super, wenn der sozusagen den Absprung geschaffen hat, von dieser Sucht jetzt zurück in diese Medienscout-Rolle und halt da auch seine Erfahrung auch da ein Stück weit weiterzugeben und dann nochmal so gebrieft zu werden, dass er halt auch mit anderen Kompetenzen glänzen kann. Weil früher war es halt nur nach dem Motto in der Klasse so ein bisschen gehänselt, naja, das ist halt der kranke Zocker. Der macht halt sonst nichts.
Aber ist diese Medienscout-Geschichte, ist das jetzt eigentlich auch in irgendeiner Form finanziell unterfüttert oder ist das jetzt einfach nur so ein Übereinkommen der beteiligten Gruppen, dass man da so ein bisschen Informationsaustausch macht und das manifestiert sich in der Miningliste? Also was heißt das?
Also im Prinzip geht es natürlich über die Stadt. Das heißt, da sind Stellen dran gebunden von den Leuten, die von der Stadt an diesem Projekt arbeiten. Also es sind Stellen geschaffen worden auch explizit für dieses Projekt sozusagen, vor allem glaube ich beim Jugendamt. Die Sachen planen, Koordinierungs-, also das Stadtmedienzentrum muss da ganz viel koordinieren, die Sachen einbinden, man muss ja schauen, an welchen Schulen geht man, welche Schulen fragen an, wen schickt man da wann hin, das muss ja auch so eine Reihenfolge irgendwie haben, wann diese Themen abgehandelt werden. Die machen dann auch mit den Kids, mit den Medienscouts so Sachen, die flettern gehen.
Und ihr seid dann sozusagen so eine der Gruppen, die mit den Medienscouts irgendwo hingehen. Aber seid ihr dann auch mal gemeinsam mit anderen Gruppen? Oder in der Regel sogar?
Also es ist unterschiedlich. Also wir sind erstmal klar Teil des Netzwerkes. Wir machen halt Arbeit innerhalb des Netzwerkes. Das Schöne ist, dass uns das ganze Orga-Foo-Thema von dem Netzwerk neue Medien abgenommen wird. Das ist super. Und dann sind wir natürlich noch autark. Aber wir machen zum Beispiel mal Veranstaltungen, haben jetzt irgendwo und die sagen, naja, wir werden gerne noch irgendjemand haben, der halt keine Ahnung, da fachkompetent in der Richtung ist. Dann können wir einfach am Netzwerk fragen, pass auf, wir brauchen jemand, der sich mit rechtlichen Situationen bei Downloading auskennt. Dann sagt er halt, okay, hier ist jemand und der kann einfach mal mitgehen. Oder wir fragen halt einfach im Netz an, wir brauchen, also in der Gruppe einfach an, wir brauchen nochmal 30 Laptops. Und dann sagt halt Stadtmedienzentrum, hier, da habt ihr 30 Laptops und dann könnt ihr halt diese Aktionen durchführen. Das heißt, wir sind gebunden und autark. Also wir profitieren alle von dem Netzwerk, ganz klar. Aber wir sind halt eigenständig. Also wenn wir jetzt eine Veranstaltung machen, steht da jetzt nicht unbedingt Netzwerk, neue Medien, sondern steht halt CCC Mannheim.
Wie viel Prozent der Events, die ihr überhaupt bestreitet, sind dann auch wirklich in dem Kontext von diesem Netzwerk? Und wie viel ist davon unabhängig?
Es werden immer weniger. Also eigentlich sind es mittlerweile sehr viel mehr unabhängige Veranstaltungen, weil eben das Problem ist, dass diese Medienscout-Ausbildung nur in Mannheim erst mal stattfindet. Das Land Baden-Württemberg hat zwar eine Initiative fürs nächste Jahr, wo das länderübergreifend passieren soll, wobei das, glaube ich, auch nicht diese Medienscouts sind, sondern einfach so Schulungen, sage ich mal, und zwar auch im großen Stil, also wo dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, tausend Schüler in eine Halle kommen und dann erzählt einer was, eine Stunde und dann gehen sie wieder.
Klingt nicht sehr effektiv.
Richtig, genau. Und da ist halt dieses Medienscout-Projekt wesentlich besser zu beurteilen, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Und wir machen aber auch, da wir in Mannheim quasi in drei Bundesländern sind, Hessen, Baden-Württemberg, Rheinland-Pfalz direkt, ist das halt so ein Problem, dass andere Länder, oder für uns ist das gut, weil wir da rausgehen können sozusagen. Wir können einfach an die anderen Länder und andere Städte hingehen und sagen, hier würden wir bei euch sowas Ähnliches machen oder so eine Veranstaltung mal machen. Was sagt ihr? Und dann sind die auch meistens begeistert.
Genau.
Und lauft ihr schon, also ist es so wirklich, dass ihr das noch an die Schulen tragt? Oder hat sich das irgendwie schon so weit rumgesprochen?
Es kommt drauf an. Also im Prinzip ist es mittlerweile so, ich will nicht sagen selbstläufer, weil das wäre jetzt übertrieben zu sagen, aber normalerweise kommen die Schulen auf uns zu.
Ja, also wir müssen definitiv nicht mehr so oft an Schulen gehen, als die uns anfragen. Also es ist definitiv, dass das aus der Richtung der Schule kommt oder den Jugendhäusern oder sonst irgendwas, die dann einfach einen Bedarf haben und uns da halt anfordern.
Also wenn du sagst Bedarf, dann muss ich nochmal nachhaken. Also das ist schon so, dass die quasi das in bestimmte Problembereiche identifiziert haben und sehen, da kommen wir auch so nicht weiter. Das ist jetzt auch für uns auch ein schulisches Problem ein Stück weit und das dann schon fast so ein bisschen mehr so das rote Telefon greifen wird.
Es gibt im Prinzip zwei Situationen. Die eine ist die unschönere Situation, die ist diese. Es ist irgendwas passiert. Die Hütte ist am Brennen. Wir brauchen jemand, der uns da hilft.
Was kann das sein?
Keine Ahnung, Cybermobbing, so ein typisches Thema.
Also ein Klassiker war das auf, ich glaube, wir hatten mal einen Fall, wo auf Schülerfahrtzeit eine Gruppe gegründet wurde, die dann irgendwie einen Lehrer beschimpft hat oder gemobbt hat. Und dann hat sich irgendwie ein Direktor anonym in Schülerfahrtzeit angemeldet, hat geguckt, wer ist alles in dieser Gruppe und hat die alle quasi abgemahnt und hat denen dann einen blauen Brief nach Hause geschickt.
Erst mal die Keule ausgerabt?
Genau, erst mal die Keule ausgerabt und dann uns angerufen und gesagt, hier kommt mal und macht da mal was, dass so was quasi nicht mehr passiert. Und das ist natürlich eine Sache, die wir auch nicht machen. Also da muss da auch ein bisschen aufpasst, für was wird man eingespannt. Also da gibt es halt schon so ein paar Leute, die da auch überhaupt gar nicht verstehen, was machen wir. Sondern die denken einfach, die machen irgendwie was mit, dass das Internet halt gut ist und so. Und dann wird das schon passen. Und da muss man halt aufpassen, für was man sich da einspannen lässt.
Also wie gesagt, einmal diese, jetzt ist was passiert, jetzt muss man herkommen, Geschichte gibt es da. Da gibt es die zweite Geschichte.
Aber da sagt der jetzt auch nicht grundsätzlich nein sagen.
Das kommt darauf an, was für ein Kontext das ist.
Aber wo habt ihr mal ja gesagt? Also wer hat so ein Szenario, wo es brennt und ihr auch sagt, da können wir zu beitragen.
Also wenn es irgendwie um dieses Buzzword Cybermobbing geht, wo tatsächlich mal ein Kind irgendwie betroffen war oder so, dann machen wir nicht explizit was zu Cybermobbing, weil wir da nicht die Spezialisten auch für sind, sondern da sollte dann eher die Caritas oder solche Leute kommen oder schulpsychologische Beratungsstellen zum Beispiel.
Also das wäre zum Beispiel auch so ein Zeitpunkt, wo ihr dann in dem Netzwerk Anfragen sagt, schickt ihr doch mal jemanden, auch wenn das erst mal bei euch gelandet ist.
Aber meistens wollen die dann trotzdem uns, weil die anderen Themen eben auch wichtig sind. Also wir sagen dann explizit, okay, wir sind niemand, wir können nicht irgendwas über Sucht erzählen, da sind wir keine Experten. Also schon, aber wir können halt fachlich nichts dazu sagen. Und wenn wir uns da vorne hinstellen und sagen, wir sind 24 Stunden am Tag online, dann ist das nicht gerade sehr glaubwürdig, wenn man dann den Kids sagt, du, vier Stunden, das ist aber ganz schön viel. Und das ist halt die eine Sache. Und die andere Sache, wo wir auch grundsätzlich immer Nein sagen, sind rechtliche Angelegenheiten. Weil da genau der gleiche Aspekt zum Tragen kommt, wir wollen uns nicht vorne hinstellen und irgendwie sagen, Torrent ist so böse. Das dürfte auf gar keinen Fall machen. Und da muss man halt einfach gucken. Da gibt es dann aber auch Fachleute dafür. Für Torrent kommt dann halt die Polizei und die darf dann halt auch die Keule auspacken, von wegen das ist alles böse. Und für die ganzen Suchtsachen gibt es dann halt Suchtberatungsstellen. Also die Schuhe ziehen wir uns nicht an.
Genau. Der zweite Punkt ist halt... Der zweite Punkt, also wie gesagt, das ist halt immer der Extremfall, irgendwas passiert, wir müssen anrücken. Der weitaus angenehmere Fall ist halt mal sagen, okay, es kommt eine Schule und die möchten halt wirklich Ausbildung von mir in Scouts machen. Das heißt, dann haben wir die Möglichkeit, über das Netzwerk das Ganze zu organisieren. Das heißt, es läuft dann so, dass dann das ganze Schuljahr einmal an einem Nachmittag eine Gruppe von Schülern im Prinzip durch dieses Netzwerk betreut wird. Das heißt, da sind wir halt ein Baustein von der ganzen Geschichte. Das heißt, es gibt halt verschiedene Themen, die einfach abgearbeitet werden, wie zum Beispiel Downloadsucht und alles, was wir halt bis jetzt schon besprochen haben, und wir uns einfach die Arbeit teilen. Das heißt, einmal ist die Polizei da, dann kommen wir irgendwann mal, dann kommt halt wieder jemand vom Jugendamt. Und so kann man sich halt über das Jahr die Arbeit teilen und hat halt dann ein Jahr diese Medien-Scouts betreut, macht das noch ein zweites Jahr.
Und das ist dann sozusagen immer dieselbe Klasse oder immer derselbe Jahrgang?
Nee, es ist immer die gleiche Gruppe, sag ich mal.
Genau, es sind unterschiedliche Klassen. Man kann sich da sozusagen freiwillig dazu bequem machen.
So eine AG quasi.
Genau, und da die freiwillig da sind und das auch eine Nachmittagsveranstaltung ist, haben die Bock drauf. Das heißt, die sind auch interessiert und die sind auch da. Also es ist dann nicht so, dass du dann nach drei Mal da bist, auf einmal sind es aus 15 genug drei. Also die sind engagiert. Engagiert, ja. Der Schwund ist sehr gering. Und man probiert das halt an die ganze Hand durchzuziehen. Und das ist halt diese Medienscout-Geschichte. Und dann natürlich noch unabhängige Anfragen, die halt reinkommen durch Veranstaltungen. Also in der Regel ist es so, wir machen irgendwann eine Veranstaltung und dann anschließend haben wir wieder irgendwie schon vier Leute, die uns anschließend anfragen.
Was wir durchaus auch machen, ist, dass wir auch mal Eltern- und Lehrer-Veranstaltungen machen. So ein Abendprogramm, irgendwie mal eine Stunde. Das ist unser Thema, dass wir sozusagen den Kids eigentlich erzählen, Eltern gerecht aufbauarbeiten und dann das den Eltern geben, mitgeben sozusagen. Und in der Regel ist es dann so, dass die den Druck bei der Schulleitung erzeugen, zu sagen, hier, da muss was gemacht werden. Wir müssen an unserer Schule irgendwas machen. Wir müssen unsere Kids schulen und wir müssen die Lehrer schulen. Und dann sind wir wieder der erste Ansprechpartner. So kommt man da relativ schön an die Projekte auch dran. Also wenn man da sich engagieren will, ist ein guter Weg, irgendwie erst mal über die Lehrer zu gehen und den Lehrern zu sagen, wir könnten so was für euch machen. Wie sieht es aus? Oder man geht halt an die Eltern, macht einen Elternabend, gestaltet mal einen Elternabend und die sagen dann in der Regel, hier ist Handlungsbedarf.
Also das heißt, jetzt an den Elternabend rangehen, um dafür zu werben, das dann letztlich bei den Schülern zu machen? Oder machen die auch tatsächlich Veranstaltungen für Eltern?
Wir machen Veranstaltungen für Eltern und versuchen, denen auch Tipps mit an die Hand zu geben, sozusagen, dass sie eben sich nicht auf ihre Filtersoftware verlassen wollen. Also das ist immer der Klassiker, dass die Eltern kommen und sagen, ja, welchen Filter können sie denn empfehlen? Gar nichts. Also wenn man so weit ist, dass man quasi über Filter nachdenkt, bei sich am Rechnen ist es eigentlich schon zu spät, weil man schiebt ja im Prinzip das Problem nur auf. Also wenn das Kind dann 18 ist und die ganzen Jahre nur hinter einem Filter gelebt hat, dann habe ich ihm immer noch nicht beigebracht, wie er irgendwie...
Medien komplett umzugehen.
Genau. Und das verstehen die werden aber.
Außer auf die technische Umgehung des Filters.
Was im Idealfall früher passiert.
Das ist halt das Problem.
So, um das mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, also es hat sich erst mal so entwickelt, ihr habt das mal so angetreten, und das Echo war eigentlich von vornherein relativ groß. Und nachdem ihr dann so ein bisschen durch ein paar harte Erfahrungen gehen musstet, hat sich das jetzt so eingeschliffen, dass ihr schon so ein relativ großes Repertoire aufgebaut habt von verschiedenen Themen, die ihr jetzt irgendwie bearbeitet. Aber ihr wisst auch irgendwie, welche Themen ihr einfach nicht bearbeiten wollt. Wenn man das nochmal so zusammendampft, was sind dann so jetzt die großen verbleibenden Themengruppen, die ihr dann auch wirklich behandelt und die ihr jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, so auseinanderhaltet?
Also eigentlich ein ganz großer Teil unseres Repertoires hat tatsächlich mit dem Internet an sich zu tun. Also wie groß ist das Ganze? Das heißt, was wir bewusst erstmal machen, ist in der ersten Viertelstunde von dem Vortrag, was ist das überhaupt? Ja, also was wir halt erzeugen wollen, ist dieses Bewusstsein, dass eben das Internet nicht greifbar ist, dass es halt riesig ist und dass Daten, die einfach in diesem Netzwerk irgendwie in diesem Ding sich bewegen, nicht so einfach zu kontrollieren sind, wie man sich das vorstellt. Also wenn da halt ein Bild im Internet steht sozusagen, dieses Bewusstsein zu haben, dass es dann irgendwo auf archive.org zehn Jahre später immer noch stehen kann, das versuchen wir halt einfach irgendwie zu schaffen. Und damit versuchen wir erstmal die Kids so ein bisschen zu überfordern, indem wir ihnen Zahlen und Fakten an den Kopf schmeißen, dass sie irgendwie gar nicht mehr wissen, war das jetzt gerade Milliarde, Million oder wie viele User und keine Ahnung. Um dann sozusagen diesen Bogen zu spannen, diese ganzen Sachen, die dort angeboten werden, die kosten wahnsinnig viel Geld für die Provider. Die müssen irgendwie auch von was leben.
Genau, also das Bewusstsein zu erzeugen, dass mit 29 Euro oder 10 Euro, was das Internet kostet im Prinzip nicht alles bezahlt ist, sondern auch das Bewusstsein zu schaffen, das kostet Geld, das kostet dem Betreiber Geld. Und darum wieder um den Bogen zu spannen, warum bietet er diesen Dienst kostenlos an, dann von diesem Gerücht aufzuräumen, dass es sich durch Werbung finanzieren kann, den man im Magazin macht.
Das scrollt ja gerade vor zwei Tagen über die Ticker. Facebook kostet pro Jahr eine Milliarde, der Betrieb.
Genau, das sind halt so, wenn die Leute dann merken, wir zeigen denen dann auch so ein Rechenzentrum von Google, so mit ein paar Fotos und zeigen denen, ja, guck mal hier, was ist denn das? Und Klimaanlage, Klimaanlage, teuer, kostet alles Geld, hier Server, wahnsinnig viel Server, kostet alles Geld und so weiter. Personal, Personal, Security und so weiter und so fort. Und dann checken die halt irgendwann, dass dieses hoch technisierte Kram, den sie da jeden Tag konsumieren, dass der richtig viel Geld kostet. Und über die Schiene versuchen wir dann sozusagen auszulösen, dass sie einfach mal drüber nachdenken, bezahle ich vielleicht im Endeffekt wirklich mit meinen Daten. Es ist quasi so eine Art neue Währung, die da irgendwie entstanden ist, mit der ich diesen Dienst finanziere im Endeffekt und möchte ich das. Und das ist genau die Entscheidung, die man dann halt den Kids überlassen muss im Endeffekt.
Also im Prinzip erst mal das Bewusstsein schaffen und dann halt können sie entscheiden, was sie machen.
Genau. Also wir sagen ja nicht hier, Google ist böse, geht da nicht hin, Facebook ist böse, geht da nicht hin. Sondern wir sagen einfach nur, so funktioniert das Ganze. Das hat Vor- und Nachteile. Ihr müsst einfach für euch selber herausfinden, ob ihr bereit seid, diesen Preis zu zahlen, um das zu konsumieren. Und das ist im Endeffekt die Message, die dahinter steht.
Das heißt, so einfach dieses Grundverständnis, wenn du das Produkt nicht kaufst, dann bist du irgendwie das.
Teil des Produkts, oder bist das Produkt sozusagen.
Okay, das ist so der eine Bereich, Internet erklären, dass das Internet unendliche Weiten, dass sich dieses Gefühl einstellt, als wenn einem gerade ein theoretischer Physiker irgendwie erklärt, wie sich das vom Urknall bis zum unendlich ausdehenden Universum so entwickelt hat. Und dass man irgendwann das Gefühl hat, das ist jetzt so, oh boah.
Genau. Was wir dann noch machen, ist, wir schieben dann noch mal ein paar Slides nach, wo jemand mal, ich glaube, es heißt irgendwie If You Printed Twitter. Da hat mal jemand gesagt, okay, mit den 7 Milliarden Tweets, die es bis zum heutigen Tag gibt, was würde passieren, wenn man die alle ausdrucken würde? Und darüber kann man dann dem Sittgläser erklären, wie groß das Internet tatsächlich ist. Also wenn sie erst mal hören, wie viele Milliarden und hier und Pipapo, das können die überhaupt nicht einordnen. Die wissen nicht mehr, wie mal eine Milliarde ist. Also ein interessanter Aspekt ist, ich glaube, wenn man Twitter ausdrucken würde, dann wären das 130.000 Kopien der King-James-Version der Bibel zum Beispiel, wenn man sich das mal verbildlichen würde. Und das sagt natürlich... Ich würde sie ja in Bäume umrechnen.
Ich finde, was sehr prägend ist, vielleicht als Einbild ist, die kennen alle diese gelben Schulbusse. Ich gucke gerade nach den Slides. Das ist halt irgendwie...
82 Schulbusse mit jeweils 84 Kindern drin. Das ist das Gewicht des Papiers, das Anbrauch.
Damit verstehen die halt, dass ein so ein Dienst, den sie vielleicht gar nicht nutzen, aber schon mal davon gehört haben, schon so viel Content produziert, dann können sie sich das irgendwie assoziieren, dass ihr Schüler-VOZ oder ihr Facebook, was da halt so passiert.
Also gerade Twitter ist ja auch ein kleiner Dienst in Anführungsstrichen, wenn man denen nämlich vermittelt hier, pass auf, 140 Zeichen nur oder wie viele sind, die man schicken kann in so einem Tweet. Wenn man sich das jetzt überlegt, das ist ja nicht so viel, was da jetzt an Daten liegt in Anführungsstrichen. Und dann merken die halt darauf hin, okay, was bedeutet das wirklich oder was sind das wirklich für Mengen und Dimensionen, in denen wir uns hier bewegen. Und dann haben die das eigentlich auch verstanden, dass das Internet nicht so diese Wolke ist. Oder für die Kids ist auch häufig so, das Internet hört bei Facebook auf. Also was wir auch schon versucht haben, ist in einem länger angelegten Workshop die Kids ein bisschen recherchieren zu lassen. Also Medienkompetenz hat ja immer mehrere Seiten. Ich glaube, es gab mal so einen Professor, der irgendwie gesagt hat, es gibt irgendwie drei Seiten der Medienkompetenz. Eine ist auf jeden Fall, wie passe ich auf meine Daten auf? Und die andere Privatsphäre. Und die andere ist auf jeden Fall, wie recherchiere ich Informationen, wie bewerte ich Informationen? Und dann hatten wir den Kids mal die Aufgabe gestellt, hier recherchiert doch mal uns einfach. Und es war halt erschreckend zu sehen, dass die im Prinzip bei Facebook aufhören. Also die machen Facebook auf, geben den Namen ein. Und wenn es da nicht steht, gibt es die Person nicht. Fertig.
Oder in Google geben halt den Namen ein. Dann finden sie halt, wenn sie jetzt eine Susi sorglos googeln, finden sie halt dann irgendwie 27.000 Millionen Hits. Und dann klicken die ersten drei links an und stellen fest, naja, das ist sie nicht. Also naja, hm.
Genau. Also Medienkompetenz hat ja nochmal eine andere Seite. Aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was wir bei Chaos macht Schule versuchen zu vermitteln.
Googelt ihr sie dann auch mal zurück?
Das machen wir auch. Also wir machen, wobei wir da ein bisschen davon abgekommen sind. Also früher hatten wir das so gemacht, dass wir tatsächlich uns im Vorfeld drei, vier Namen haben geben lassen und dann einfach mal zusammengetragen haben, was es alles gibt über die Person. Und das war teilweise richtig erschreckend und ist auch teilweise eskaliert. Also wir hatten mal einen Fall, wo tatsächlich Dessousfotos von einer Neunklässlerin im Netz irgendwo aufgetaucht sind. Genau, das war nicht zu gut, ja. Und da muss man dann halt so ein bisschen aufpassen. Das haben wir dann natürlich auch nicht gezeigt, logischerweise in unserer Vorform. Was wir aber machen, ist, wir haben ein Tool gebaut, das die Facebook-Freundesliste mal als Graf darstellt. Und da sieht man relativ schnell auf den ersten Blick, welche Freundeskreise gibt es? Wie gut ist derjenige vielleicht auch integriert? Im Sinne von hat der nur einen riesig großen Freundeskreis und die kennen sich alle untereinander? Oder gibt es da tatsächlich Freundeskreise, die unabhängig voneinander existieren? Und was wir immer machen, ist, entweder schießen wir dieses Tool auf Freiwillige im Publikum, wenn die Zeit es erlaubt und die Bandbreite es erlaubt. Oder wir haben vorgefertigte Graphen von real existierenden Personen auf Facebook, die wir dann einfach mal mit den Kids zusammen analysieren. Wo wir denen einfach mal zeigen, okay, hier ist der Freundeskreis, guck mal hier. Wenn man da die Leute anklickt, das sind alle in der Burschenschaft oder so. Hier ist irgendwie der Vater und da oben ist der Familienfreundeskreis. Und das kommt eigentlich immer relativ gut an, weil die dann schon relativ erschrocken sind, was man allein aus der Freundesliste über eine Person sagen kann. Also die Freundesliste oder die Freunde verraten im Endeffekt dann mehr über einen, als man selbst preisgibt.
Genau, also das ist halt auch da ein Stück weit zu verdeutlichen, naja, wenn wir als Externe, die nicht jetzt Facebook sind, solche Informationen schon aus dieser Grafik schließen können, was kann dann eigentlich dann alles Facebook? Und das ist auch so ein Stück weit Denkanstoß für die, ja. Das sind jetzt nur die öffentlich sichtbaren Informationen, die wir hier auswerten und konnten uns jetzt schon so viele Zusammenhänge ja, erklären und dann, was ist natürlich dann mit diesen, was passiert sonst noch alles damit?
Wie tiefgreifend sind denn so die Reaktionen? Ich meine, ihr sagt jetzt irgendwie, kommt gut an, ist schon erschreckend.
Also kommt gut an.
Ich meine, was, was, was kriegt ihr so einen unmittelbaren Feedback so nach der Sache?
Ich kann vielleicht ein Beispiel dazu nennen, ist, wenn wir einen Account, soll ich das mal nennen?
Du meinst jetzt da mit dem MoF?
Genau, richtig.
Ja, aber wobei da das natürlich besser bei den Eltern klappt. Bei den Kids ist da eher das deplatziert, sozusagen. Aber erzähl mal.
Okay, ich erzähl mal eine kleine Anekdote. Wir machen öfters mal, wenn wir in die Klasse gehen, mal, was ist das, ein Schüler-VZ-Account, und klicken halt mal, einen Tag vorher, etliche User mal angucken, wie viel wir mal kriegen. Vielleicht, hoffentlich auch aus der Schule einige Leute. Und...
Einen Tag vorher.
Also 24 Stunden vorher ist unser Leben. Dann gucken wir mal, wie viele Leute wir klicken können, um wie viele Freunde, in Anführungszeichen, wir dann am nächsten Tag haben, um uns da auch den Kittys zu zeigen. Ja, und mittlerweile ist es, sag ich mal, als positive Reaktion, wenn wir so einen Account erstellen in der Schule, wo wir schon mal so was gemacht haben, vielleicht mit anderen Klassen, dass wir dann irgendwann auf dieser Pin-Wand dieses Users dann irgendwie die Kommentare haben, oh, klickt den nicht an, das sind die wieder vom CCC, das ist ein Fake-Account und so weiter. Das heißt, die werden dazu schon ein bisschen sensibilisiert, obwohl wir uns bei der Account-Gestaltung relativ viel Mühe geben. Das ist schon sehr liebevoll.
Was da auch ein Aspekt ist, was ich gemeint habe mit den Eltern, ist, wir zeigen bei Schüler-VZ immer, was passiert, wenn man sich das allererste Mal bei Schüler-VZ einloggt und auf seine Freundesliste klickt. Da steht nämlich dann tatsächlich, du hast keine Freunde. Und deine Reaktion ist genau die Reaktion, die jeder hat.
Ich denke gleich an South Park.
Und wenn wir das den Eltern zeigen, ist das auch die Reaktion. Erstmal, die lachen natürlich erstmal, aber im Endeffekt hört dieses Lachen dann relativ schnell auf, weil man halt einfach weiß, wenn da jetzt ein 10-Jähriger oder ein 12-Jähriger sitzt und liest, und vielleicht sitzt noch der beste Kumpel nebendran, weil der eh schon bei Schüler-VZ ist und 100 Freunde hat, dann ist es natürlich, was löst das in so einem Kind aus? Der Witz an der Sache ist nämlich, wenn man sich bei Studi-VZ anmeldet, dann steht da nicht, du hast keine Freunde, sondern da steht da Freunde Doppelpunkt Null. Und das ist nochmal was ganz anderes, als wenn mir jemand sozusagen diesen Satz ins Gesicht sagt, in Anfangstrichen, du hast keine Freunde, besorg dir jetzt welche los. Und das kommt bei den Eltern gut an, im Sinne von, das erzeugt nochmal so dieses Gefühl dafür, dass die schon mit so kleinen Tricks auch arbeiten, also diese ganzen Anbieter, sag ich jetzt mal. Und was bei den Kids sehr gut ankommt, ist eigentlich diese Demo mit dem Graf, weil die dann schon so ein bisschen ins Grübeln kommen und sich einfach denken so, okay, die Information, ich muss nicht...
Also mit dem Graf, mit dieser grafischen...
Genau, genau, der Facebook-Freundesliste sozusagen. Da wird ganz gut klar für die Kids, dass die merken, ich muss eigentlich nicht nur auf meine Daten aufpassen, sondern ich muss eigentlich auch auf die Daten von meinen Freunden aufpassen. Weil im Endeffekt, wenn die ihre Daten nicht schützen, wenn da irgendwas steht, dann könnte mich das auch mitunter betreffen. Und das hat nochmal diesen Effekt, dass die dann auch untereinander vielleicht ein bisschen mehr aufpassen, so nach dem Motto hier, ich hab irgendwie da ein Bild von dir gefunden und hier, da kannst du das vielleicht mal irgendwie wegnehmen oder das möchte ich nicht, dass ich da verlinkt bin oder so. Einfach dieses Bewusstsein erzeugen, dass man versuchen kann, wenigstens Herr über seine Daten zu sein und einfach die Verantwortung zu übernehmen für die Daten, für die eigenen und für die Daten von anderen.
Ihr seid seit 2006 jetzt an dem Thema? Also fünf Jahre. Hat sich in den fünf Jahren da irgendwas geändert?
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall besser geworden. Also es gibt auch eine Studie, die das eindeutig belegt. Die GIMM Studie, die jedes Jahr rauskommt. Also es gibt die GIMM Studie und die GIMM Studie. Und die versucht, den Medienkonsum von Kindern und Jugendlichen so ein bisschen statistisch mal zu erfassen. Und gibt es als PDF auch zum Download frei verfügbar. Jedes Jahr kommt die raus.
Wer macht das?
Das macht, glaube ich, Nordrhein-Westfalen?
Ja, ich weiß es gerade nicht. Also irgendwie ein Land mit, also es ist auf jeden Fall mit staatlicher Unterstützung.
Genau, mit pädagogischer Forschung.
Genau. Das ist glaube ich in der Pfalz sitzen, meines Wissens. Und da sieht man relativ schön, dass über die Jahre hinweg, also wir haben es gerade mal da, genau, wenn man das mal gerade so sagt, ja, hast du mal noch die andere Statistik mit den Privacy-Optionen? Also man sieht, was die auch untersuchen, ist, wie denn die Privacy-Optionen, wer benutzt denn Privacy-Optionen in den sozialen Netzwerken, wer stellt die denn überhaupt ein? Und da sieht man relativ schön, dass irgendwie vom Jahr 2009 aufs Jahr 2010, meine ich, irgendwie 20 Prozent mehr von den Kids tatsächlich ihre Privacy-Optionen aktiviert haben als vorher. Und das ist natürlich schon mal eine Hausnummer. Also das, was man tut, um nochmal den Schluss oder den Anfang anzuknüpfen, sozusagen, das bringt tatsächlich was und man kann da was tun.
Also wir bilden uns ein, dass wir da vielleicht unseren Beitrag geleistet haben zu der ganzen Geschichte.
Die ganze Aufklärungsarbeit bringt tatsächlich was. Also das zeigt sich auch in den Statistiken. Die Kids sind auch viel sensibilisierter. Man merkt auch teilweise, dass wenn die bei uns in Veranstaltungen kommen, dass die sagen, ja, wir waren vor einer Woche, waren wir auch schon auf einer Veranstaltung, haben uns das angehört. Und dann denkt man halt erstmal, oh je, jetzt pennen die einem alle weg, haben die alles schon gehört. Aber im Endeffekt sind die Themen, die man denen dann nochmal so rüberbringt, nochmal was anderes. Also wie gesagt, das Image macht da wahrscheinlich auch viel einfach. Und die Art und Weise, wie wir mit den Themen umgehen, ist wahrscheinlich eine sehr viel offenere, als wenn da vorne ein Polizist steht, der irgendwie vielleicht auch bedingt einfach ein paar Sachen sagen muss.
Ich meine so, okay, ihr kommt da so mit dem Hacker-Image rein, aber wenn ihr da wieder rausgeht, dann könnte sich das ja auch gleich geändert haben. Sind die dann irgendwie erstmal enttäuscht, dass er...
Also eigentlich sind die immer begeistert. Und wenn die rausgehen, haben auch im Nachhinein noch Fragen. Also es gibt oft Kids, die irgendwie hinterher noch da stehen und Fragen haben. Und ich glaube eher, dass es dazu beiträgt, dass die Kids eben ein differenzierteres Bild vom Hacker bekommen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es mit einem Imageverlust zu tun hat, dass man jetzt auf einmal eben...
Haben von Einzelne dann auch bei euch irgendwie im Club aufgelaufen?
Nein, weil siebte Klasse ist halt immer so... Die sind halt irgendwie 13, 14 oder was. Und da sind die noch zu jung dafür. Aber es gibt immer wieder Fragen.
Es gibt ja schon seit fünf Jahren.
Es gab mal ein paar Lehrer, die vorbeigekommen sind, was ich ganz cool fand. Es gab Lehrer, die vorbeigekommen sind tatsächlich. Und die Kids schreiben manchmal noch E-Mails. Und wenn sie mal eine Frage haben, dann kommen immer noch E-Mails. Und was immer kommt, sind dass zwei, drei Leute sich erkundigen, kann man bei euch vorbeikommen.
Das ist also eigentlich das schönste Feedback. Man merkt, wenn die jetzt nicht unbedingt nach dieser Doppelstunde direkt in die nächste Unterrichtsstunde oder in die Pause müssen, dass er einfach dann noch ein paar da bleibt und noch ein paar Fragen hat, oder Feedback per E-Mail kommt, das ist dann immer schon das Schönste, dass man weiß, ok, das hat was gebracht. Weil, ja, das ist eigentlich so.
Jetzt ist ja, hast du ja eingangs schon erwähnt so, Chaos macht Schule, mehr oder weniger zeitgleich ging es dann auch in Hamburg los. Es ist ja auch generell so, es gibt das jetzt nicht nur in Mannheim, sondern das ist jetzt schon etwas, was sich über auch jetzt, sagen wir mal, die R-Verkreise des CCC ausgebreitet hat. Was hat sich da jetzt ergeben? Gibt es da schon irgendeine funktionierende Ergänzung? Trifft man sich da?
Also wir hatten in Bad Honnef, dieses Jahr, weiß ich nicht, vor zwei Monaten, im Oktober, es war am 28. oder 30. Oktober, ein Meeting sozusagen, ein Treffen in Bad Honnef, wo alle Airfars, die irgendwas im Entferntesten auch nur mit Chaos macht Schule zu tun haben, sich mal getroffen haben, um einfach mal so initial sich so die Kräfte zu bündeln, zu gucken, was machen die anderen, ein paar Absprachen zu treffen und zu schauen, wie kann man sich organisieren.
Das war das erste Mal, dass du das gefunden hast?
Ganz genau.
Und wie viele Gruppen waren das? Wie verbreitet ist das jetzt?
Ich glaube, elf Gruppen waren das. Manche Gruppen sind natürlich noch nicht so weit. Die waren einfach nur da, um sich das mal anzuhören, weil sie interessiert sind. Manche Gruppen haben auch ein Wort-Vortragsprogramm und haben schon Veranstaltungen gemacht. Andere Gruppen verstehen, dass Chaos macht Schule was anderes. Die basteln eher mit den Kindern zusammen, probieren darüber, Inhalte zu vermitteln. Das ist also so ein bisschen... Genau, differenzierte Ansätze in der ganzen... in dieser Gruppe, ja. Und ja, dementsprechend war halt in Bad Honnef so ein Treffen, mal einfach zu gucken, was machen die eigentlich alle? Und einfach mal zu gucken, was für Ideen man haben kann und wie man das Ganze ein bisschen besser organisieren kann. Wir sind zwar Fan der Dezentralisierung, aber halt so ein paar verschiedene Ansätze halt auch...
Vor allem ist es halt auch mal wichtig, die Leute kennenzulernen, die tatsächlich hinter den Projekten stehen, damit man im Zweifelsfall vielleicht auch mal fragen kann. Und es gibt auch eine Mailing-Liste, eine Chaos macht Schule Mailing-Liste. Und wenn da halt jetzt Anfragen einschlagen, dann werden die halt sehr viel effektiver beantwortet, sag ich mal, weil man eben weiß, ah, Moment mal, in Mannheim, da gibt es doch jemand. Und das ist irgendwie die Anfrage, kommt aus der Nähe, also will das nicht jemand von euch machen und so. Das heißt, das ist jetzt schon, würde ich sagen, effektiver geworden auf jeden Fall, aber da ist noch Luft nach oben. Also man kann das noch ausweiten.
Ihr macht das ja ehrenamtlich. Also es wird da kein Geld für gezahlt, dass ihr da auftritt, aber trotzdem fällt da ja Arbeit an und Reisekosten und Pippa-Pro.
Also manchmal ist es in der Tat so, dass wir Geld nehmen. Also für diese Medienscouts-Sachen nehmen wir nichts, weil das halt irgendwie über die Stadt läuft natürlich und da lassen wir uns nicht für bezahlen, das ist natürlich klar. Was wir machen ist, wir gucken einfach, wir sprechen vorher mit den Schulen und fragen die einfach, wollt ihr nicht unseren Honorar zahlen? Und dann können die im Endeffekt selber entscheiden, wie hoch dieses Honorar ausfällt. Und dann nehmen wir das sozusagen. Also das ist sozusagen der Deal, den wir haben. Weil, wie du schon gesagt hast, da viel Arbeit drinsteckt, manchmal auch Weg drinsteckt. Also wir waren auch schon mal eine dreiviertel Stunde mit dem Auto unterwegs, um Chaos macht Schule zu machen. Und wenn dann halt vier Leute irgendwie sich auch vorher noch mal treffen müssen, um da Schüler zu stalken auf Facebook und irgendwelche Dinge zu tun, dann kostet das alles Zeit. Und im Endeffekt ist das für unseren Club natürlich auch eine schöne Einnahmequelle nebenher, um unsere Raumfinanzierung zu denken zum Beispiel.
Also so sich die Schulen das quasi nach eigenen Ermessen auch leisten können.
Wir nehmen dann natürlich auch keine Unsummen. Also das ist natürlich nichts, wo wir jetzt irgendwie sagen.
Aber das fließt dann quasi auch direkt in den Club?
Also ich denke, du bist ein bisschen da konkurrenzlos günstig zu den kommerziellen Anbietern, die es da auf dem freien Markt gibt, die sowas ähnliches halt gestalten.
Kommerzielle Anbieter, die gibt es auch.
Genau, die gibt es auch. Also natürlich weiß man nicht so genau, was man davon halten soll, weil im Prinzip geht es ja um die gleiche Sache. Und das ist eine gute, nämlich den Kids irgendwie Medienkompetenz zu vermitteln. Und was aber so ein bisschen das Problem ist, ist, dass diese kommerziellen Anbieter so ein bisschen immer in Massenveranstaltungen ausarten. Und ich würde eher sagen, dass eine Veranstaltung in einem etwas privateren Kreis, wo man auch mal vielleicht eine Frage stellen kann, die man in einem großen Rahmen, wo 75 Prozent der Leute, die drin sitzen, man überhaupt nicht kennt, dass es vielleicht einfach besser ist, wenn man das in einem kleinen Rahmen stellen kann. Und deswegen tendieren wir eigentlich dazu, wie wir ja schon am Anfang gesagt haben, irgendwie mehr als 70 Leute ist eigentlich schon fast zu viel, weil dann eben diese Kommunikation nicht mehr gegeben ist. Und das ist eben ein großes Manko von den kommerziellen Anbietern.
Ich kenne natürlich auch die Inhalte diesen ganzen kommerziellen Anbietern nicht. Also ich weiß auch nicht, was die probieren, halt zu vermitteln und wie sie es probieren zu vermitteln, ob sie da mit dem, sage ich mal, eher die Interessen der Schulen vermitteln, die da halt sagen, naja, gut, wir brauchen halt jemand, der jetzt irgendwie darüber geht, dass Facebook doch böse ist und vielleicht das Ganze nicht ganz so differenziell betrachtet, wie wir das betrachten. Das weiß man natürlich auch nicht.
Also die lassen sich da auch nicht in die Karten gucken, natürlich, logischerweise.
Aber wundermich, mal kommerzielle Anbieter heißt ja, da muss ja auch irgendwelche Kunden dafür geben, wenn die Schulen sich sowas überhaupt leisten.
Meistens ist das ein Sponsoring dann im Endeffekt. Also da kommt dann irgendwie eine Bank oder eine, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie ein lokal ansässiger Firma oder so, Großunternehmer, der das dann irgendwie für drei, vier Schulen oder für mehrere Schulklassen sponsert sozusagen. Das ist auch eine Sache, wo wir ein bisschen aufpassen müssen, weil wir da häufig auch mit ins Boot geholt werden wollen. Und da hat man halt immer das Problem, wenn man dann da steht und das Banner dann der Volksbank oder der Sparkasse irgendwie über einem thront, dann ist es natürlich ein Konflikt.
Das wollen wir auch nicht.
Genau, deswegen sagen wir bei solchen Sachen, also wir sagen immer, wenn ihr uns was zahlen wollt, macht das. Aber dann zahlt das die Schule als Honorar fertig. Aber wir lassen uns nicht über einen Sponsoring extern sozusagen bezahlen, dass da eine Bank oder eine Sparkasse kommt.
Oder was weiß ich, eine Partei oder ein Verein oder irgend sowas. Also da sind wir ja sehr, sehr differenziert.
Ja, da wollen wir einen großen Unterschied machen. Das ist unsere Veranstaltung. Wenn wir kommen, machen wir unsere Veranstaltung. Dann machen wir unser Ding sozusagen. Oder wir machen es nicht. Wir können uns natürlich auch auf Kompromisse einlassen. Wenn wirklich gesagt wird, irgendwie ja, bei uns gab es da halt hier und da ein Problemchen, könnt ihr da was dazu sagen, dann machen wir das gern. Logisch. Aber wir erzählen unser Ding und lassen uns dafür nichts einspannen. Also es ist auch eine ganz wichtige Sache, da integer zu bleiben sozusagen. Sonst ist ja auch die Glaubwürdigkeit irgendwann mal weg. Also wenn man jedem irgendwie nach dem Mund redet, und mal hier steht und das eine sagt, und dann dort steht und das andere sagt, das ist ja auch nicht Sinn der Sache.
Was natürlich jetzt über diesem ganzen Ding die ganze Zeit so schwebt, ist so dieses so, da muss von außen was in die Schulen reingetragen werden, was die Lehrer offensichtlich selbst nicht leisten können oder wollen. Ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich auch kein wünschenswerter Zustand, weil eigentlich ist ja genau dafür nun das Lehrertum auch da. Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, man muss da mehr Erwartungen haben an die Lehrer. Das ist sicherlich kein Berufsbild, was man groß beneiden kann, weil da stehen sie einfach auch unter einem enormen Druck und Erwartungshaltung. Aber letzten Endes ist es natürlich schon so, dass da ja auch jetzt eine Lehrergeneration auch mit heranwachsen muss, dass man eigentlich gar nicht mal nur den Schülern irgendwie die ganze Zeit was erzählen muss, oder?
Ja, das Krasse ist, wir hatten eine Veranstaltung dieses Jahr mit Pädagogen, Lehrern, die in der Ausbildung sind, richtig? Und das sind also Leute in unserem Alter. Und da waren wir auch erstaunt, wie wenig die wissen. Also, sie sind halt Benutzer dieser Plattform, aber haben das Ganze auch nicht hinterfragt, oder? Sich mal überlegt. Also, teilweise muss man die genauso briefen und schulen wie die 5-, 6-, 7-Klasse. Also, da unterscheiden sie sich echt nur marginal.
Also, Lehrer-Ausbildung macht ihr auch sozusagen?
Genau, genau.
Also, Eltern, Schüler und Lehrer, ist eigentlich alles dabei.
Wundekatzen.
Ja, alles, was twittern kann.
Genau, richtig.
Und vor allem alles, was man nicht wüttern kann.
Also, bei den Lehrern ist halt das Problem, dass, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, dieser Konflikt so ein bisschen da ist, dass die Eltern eigentlich meinen, die Lehrer müssten es machen, und die Lehrer meinen, die Eltern müssten es machen. Und irgendwie ist beides richtig. Weil, wenn man sich mal anguckt, dass es sich hier irgendwie nicht um ein Hobby handelt bei den Kids, das ist ja nicht wie auf dem Fußballplatz gehen und da irgendwie Fußball spielen und im Verein sein, das ist was ganz anderes. Das ist ja irgendwie eine Lebenseinstellung und das ist irgendwie ein ganz neues Lebensgefühl, was diese Kids auch haben mit diesen, in Anführungsstrichen, neuen Medien. So neu sind sie ja nicht.
Das ist im Prinzip der Lebensraum. Also dementsprechend bewegen die sich da drin. Es ist also nicht wie, wie du schon sagtest, ein Sportverein, da gehe ich hin und mache das drei Stunden und dann mache ich was anderes. Das ist ja alltagsbegleitend auch.
Genau. Und deswegen ist es eben wichtig, dass diese Themen sowohl in der Schule behandelt werden, nicht mal als eigenes Fach. Also ich würde gar nicht mal fordern, dass man irgendwie sagt, oh man muss jetzt da Datenschutz und Medienkompetenz irgendwie schulen, sondern für mich gehört das irgendwie so Hand in Hand. Also das muss in jedem Unterrichtsfach, muss einfach diese Medienkompetenz vermittelt werden, weil es in jedem Fach Reibungspunkte zu den neuen Medien einfach gibt. Und da muss das irgendwie angesetzt werden. Genauso muss es aber daheim auch irgendwo untergebracht werden. Wenn die Kids nach Hause kommen, dann dürfen sie nicht alleine gelassen werden. Ein ganz großes Problem ist immer, dass die Kids versuchen, ihr Mediendasein, den Umgang mit den neuen Medien dazu zu benutzen, dass sie sich von ihren Eltern abgrenzen. Also das ist so was, wo man als Siebtklässler irgendwie schön sagen kann, ich habe hier was, was du nicht kannst, wo du dir nicht auskennst, wo du keinen Plan von hast und wo ich dir überlegen bin. Und ich möchte auch nicht, dass du da einen Blick bekommst, weil das ist mein Ding. Und wenn man da als Elternteil sozusagen derjenige ist, der den ersten Schritt macht und sagt, ich beweise dir meine Kompetenz, indem ich mit dir zusammen vielleicht dein Facebook-Profil einrichte und dir zeige, worauf du achten musst bei Datenschutz und so weiter, dann bin ich vielleicht auch als Elternteil Ansprechpartner in dem Zweifelsfall, wenn mal was schief geht, weil eben diese Brücke geschlagen ist und diese Wand nicht mehr da ist, diese Abgrenzung nicht mehr da ist. Und das versuchen wir auch immer zu vermitteln, dass die Eltern da offensiver mit den Sachen umgehen sollten, sich vielleicht auch selber mal ein Facebook-Profil machen, damit sie wissen, von was irgendwie gesprochen wird, sich mit der Sache beschäftigen. Sie sollen keine Spezialisten werden, aber sollen sich einfach auf die Dinge einlassen, damit sie mit ihren Kindern im Zweifelsfall richtig arbeiten können.
So eine gewisse Grundkompetenz fordern wir eigentlich da. Und das Schöne ist ja, wir können ja den Eltern auch genug Mittel und Möglichkeiten und Informationen an die Hand geben. Auch jemand, der sich mit der Thematik noch nie vorher beschäftigt hat, einfach mal, sag ich mal, einen groben Abriss zu bekommen. Und wenn er sich dann wirklich dafür interessiert und das machen möchte, das auch Infomaterial an die Hand zu geben, zu sagen, okay, hier so, das ist alles zu beachten, so läuft das Ganze ab. Also wir haben da auch eine ganz gute Kooperation, kommen wir schon gar nicht mehr, Partnerschaft mit, wie kann man das sagen, Clicksafe?
Ja, Kooperation würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen, weil Clicksafe ja durchaus auch so halb kommerziell ist. Ja, das ist richtig, ja. Aber Clicksafe sind halt die Leute, die irgendwie so ein paar Flyer drucken, wo die wesentlichen Informationen irgendwie drinstehen, für Kinder, für Eltern, für Lehrer, für alle möglichen Zielgruppen. Und da stehen einfach so die relevanten Einstiegspunkte mal drin. Was bedeutet auch dieses ganze Wording, was es da gibt, was ist jetzt Cybermobbing und was ist irgendwie ein Clan und eine LAN-Party und was weiß ich, diese ganzen Sachen, die werden da halt mal irgendwie kurz erklärt, offline, schön zum Blättern und Lesen und ja.
Was ist jetzt Clicksafe genau?
Clicksafe ist aus EU-Geldern eine Institution, die hat die Aufgabe bekommen, so Informationsmaterial zu dem Thema neue Medien im wertesgehenden Sinne einfach zu erzeugen. Das heißt, die müssen halt irgendwo bei der EU-Ressenschaft abziehen und sagen halt, naja, wir haben halt irgendwie 40.000 Flyer gemacht und mit diesen Informationen drin, mit den aktuellen Themen und die sind eigentlich auch, sag ich mal, ganz dankbar, dass wir die Sache einfach abnehmen, weil sie dann einfach vorweisen können, okay, ihre Arbeit macht Sinn. Und zum Zweiten ist das Material weitestgehend eigentlich ganz brauchbar. Auch über Creative Commons Lizenz, also die machen das schon ganz cool. Also nicht alle Sachen sind da, wo wir sagen, finden wir gut. Aber so diverse Flyer, die kann man einfach bedenkenlos weggeben, wo wir auch sagen, das ergänzt sich oder passt ganz gut zu unseren Themen, zu unseren Meinungen. Also da steht jetzt nicht irgendwie drin, dass alle Hackerböse den Klick hatten, Informationen klauen, passt auf, sondern da ist es auch relativ neutral erklärt oder neutral dargestellt. Dementsprechend kann man halt den Eltern das einfach mal empfehlen und an die Hand geben. So sparen wir uns auch ein Stück weit auch selbst die ganze Flyer- und Produktionsgeschichte, weil es ist relativ aufwendig, immer da Information up to date zu haben. Und man möchte natürlich schon den Eltern noch was mitgeben, wo sie einfach daheim nochmal sich in Ruhe hinsetzen können und einfach das nachzulesen.
Bei den Lehrern ist halt ein bisschen das Problem, da kommt man halt mit Flyern nicht weiter. Weil eigentlich müssten die in ihrer Ausbildung diese Dinge vermittelt bekommen und auch im Zweifelsfall den Umgang vermittelt bekommen. Es gibt auch ganz viele Lehrer, die sich überfördert fühlen, wenn wirklich dieses Thema Cybermobbing aufkommt. Also was passiert denn da wirklich in den sozialen Netzwerken? Wo kann man da irgendwie ansetzen? Und da sehe ich halt auch wieder irgendwie das Land sozusagen, beziehungsweise den Staat gefragt, der da eigentlich mal ein bisschen intervenieren müsste. Problem an der Sache ist halt das Bildung, Ländersache. Jeder kocht sein eigenes Süppchen. In manchen Ländern gibt es solche Sachen. An manchen Universitäten gibt es diese Medienkompetenz-Geschichten, die den Lehrern vermittelt werden. Aber es gibt halt auch Unis, an denen das überhaupt kein Thema ist. Also Medienkompetenz betäuft sich meistens darauf, wie benutze ich einen Beamer, wie schließe ich da den Laptop an und wie benutze ich dieses digitale Whiteboard. Aber dass da mal tatsächlich jemand kommt und hinter die Kulissen blickt und einfach mal erklärt, was hat es denn mit diesen Geschichten wirklich auf sich? Was passiert denn da wirklich? Das findet meines Wissens danach so nicht in ausreichendem Maße statt. Und das ist ein ganz großes Problem.
Wie sieht ihr denn jetzt so die unmittelbare Zukunft von dem Chaos macht Schule? Was steht denn da eigentlich jetzt an?
Also ich finde, das ist jetzt mit Bündelung der Kräften sozusagen, kriegt das noch einen ganz anderen Wind. Also wir möchten vielleicht auch da eine Forderung mal einfach mal in die Öffentlichkeit tragen, also irgendein Paper, wo wir sagen können, wir als CCC möchten gerne, dass das irgendwie in den Schulen, bei den Lehrern, also im Alltag sozusagen ankommt. Und natürlich auch, man merkt, das Thema ist interessant. Es können viele Gruppen machen. Man erreicht einen ganz, ganz guten Erfolg damit. Man erreicht damit Leute. Also ich finde, das ist echt ein guter Bildungsauftrag, den man da...
Ja, also was die nahe Zukunft halt angeht, glaube ich, dass das Projekt noch eine Weile existieren wird, weil der Bedarf nach wie vor da ist. Und auch immer mehr, man merkt immer so, welche Regionen gerade so ein bisschen umkippen und wo die Regionen sozusagen dann sagen, oh, jetzt müssen wir das machen. Die Nachbarschule hat das gemacht. Und eigentlich brauchen wir auch sowas und so. Und da merkt man, dass das dann so Wellen schlägt, sage ich mal. Und meine Hoffnung wäre aber, dass dieses Projekt irgendwie sich irgendwann mal in nichts auflöst, weil es einfach ganz klar ist, dass die Generation, die sozusagen jetzt heranwächst, in ausreichender Form diese ganzen Werte ihren Kindern mal vermitteln kann. Und damit ist die Sache eigentlich gegessen. Weil wenn das irgendwo in der Entziehung ankommt, wenn Eltern ihre Kinder dahingehend, also ich kann mich da an meine Jugend zum Beispiel erinnern, bei mir war das erstens so, mein Vater hat sich mit mir an den Rechner gesetzt, an den 80, 88er, und hat mit mir Larry 1 gezockt. Und als ich da noch ein kleiner Bub von 10 Jahren oder so war, da war das schon ein relativ pornöses Spiel für damalige Verhältnisse. Und mein Vater saß halt mit mir da am Rechner, und dann war er in dem Fall auch Ansprechpartner für diese ganzen wilden Dinge, die da passiert sind. Und so stelle ich mir das eben einfach vor, dass diese Probleme gar nicht mehr auftauchen in dieser Form, wie sie momentan existieren, weil eben die Eltern ganz viel abfangen können, weil die die Ansprechpartner für die Kids sind und nicht mehr wir sozusagen. Das wäre der Idealfall.
Also ich wünsche mir so ein bisschen, dass das Chaos macht Schule einfach in die Gesellschaft mit einfließt, und es einfach kein Thema mehr ist. Das ist einfach allgegenwärtig, wie ich weiß, dass ich mir nicht die Finger an der Herdplatte verbrennen soll.
Der klassische Beispiel von früher ist Steig nicht zu Fremden ins Auto. Das haben mir meine Eltern auch eingetrichtert. Das muss halt irgendwie mit den sozialen Netzwerken und mit den neuen Medien in Anfangstrichen auch irgendwie in diese Richtung gehen. Und ich glaube, dann haben wir extrem viel erreicht, wenn das ankommt. Aber die Richtung wird halt jetzt vorgegeben. Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt, irgendwie zu sagen, wie viel Raum nimmt Datenschutz und Privatsphäre ein im Leben von den heranwachsenden Generationen, die es jetzt gibt? Und wenn wir da jetzt nicht agieren, dann wird das extrem schwer, glaube ich.
Ich denke, eh, dass wir schon relativ spät dran sind. Ich denke, wir hätten das Thema schon vor zig Jahren adressieren können oder behandeln können, wie wir es heute hier und jetzt behandeln. Es wurde so die ganze Zeit vielleicht auch aus diesem Hackertum so ein bisschen runtergespielt. Man heißt es halt irgendwie nicht cooles Programm schreiben oder irgendwelche coole Dinge machen, sondern das ist so ein bisschen so ein soziales Thema. Das war vielleicht nie so, ja, so auf dem Radar. Und zum Zweiten gab es vielleicht auch nicht die richtigen Personen, die sich so ein Thema annehmen können, weil der klassische Nerd oder Geek ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt der Mensch, der halt so was vermitteln kann.
Ich denke, man hat halt auch irgendwie einen anderen Blick auf die Sache. Also wenn du dich tagtäglich mit TCP IP rumschlägst und irgendwie da krassen Code schreibst, dann hast du vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr im Endeffekt den Blick, dass diese ganz simplen Sachen ganz, ganz vielen Leuten Probleme bereiten und dass ganz, ganz simple Dinge überhaupt nicht mehr gesehen werden können von Autonormalverbrauchern oder eben auch von den Kids, ja, weil eben keiner da ist, der es ihnen zeigt, keiner da ist, der Ansprechpartner ist. Die Kids werden quasi in so einen Topf geschmissen und dann sollen sie da im Wasser irgendwie des großen, weiten Internets einfach schwimmen. Man kann es ihnen nicht so richtig verbieten, was auch gut so ist, aber man kann halt auch sie nicht an der Hand nehmen und sagen, so hier, da, da, da, so ist es, ja, und jetzt schwimmen. Und das ist eben irgendwie, glaube ich, das ganz, ganz große Problem.
Man merkt halt genau bei diesen Erklärungen, wie funktioniert das Internet, dass allein das schon nicht vermittelt wurde. Und das sind ja eigentlich, wenn sie sich in diese Medien bewegen sollen, das ist eigentlich die Grundlagen. Also wenn ich ein Auto fahren möchte, muss ich auch irgendwie einen Führerschein machen. Und dementsprechend denke ich halt, wenn schon das Grundwissen nicht da ist, wie sollen sie dann darauf aufbauen, sich selbst orientieren überhaupt?
Die machen halt Learning by Doing gerade, und das geht halt häufig in die Hose, wenn man sie lässt, logischerweise. Die andere Seite natürlich möchte.
Aber ihr habt es ja auch so gelernt.
Ja, aber zu meiner Zeit, wenn ich mir so überlege, meine Eltern waren auch nicht begeistert, als ich mir meinen ersten Internetanschluss geholt habe. Das war da auch schon noch so, das ist böse, und nachts brauchen wir doch nett, und es gibt es doch eh nicht mehr so lang, und was weiß ich. Das setzt man aus. Genau. Und wenn ich mir überlege, dass wenn ich damals schon die Dienste quasi zur Verfügung gehabt hätte, die es heute gibt, dann weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich da so kritisch mit umgehen würde aus heutiger Sicht, sage ich jetzt mal. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man, wenn man da in dieses Wasser geworfen wird, nicht einfach gar keine Möglichkeit hat, auch das kritisch irgendwie zu erleben. Schon gar nicht, wenn man ein Siebtklässler ist. Also ich meine, hallo, man hat das Internet, die Welt steht offen. Ich kann irgendwie an jedem Ort mit 100 Leuten chatten. Ich habe eine Freundesliste von 1.400 Leuten und solche Geschichten. Da denke ich nicht drüber nach, was das auslöst.
Smartphone in der Tasche, das ist auch ganz krass in den Klassen. Man guckt die Handy-Entwicklung, also Handy haben sie eh alle. Und dann wer davon alles schon ein Smartphone hat und dann ein Smartphone mit einem Datentarif dazu. Das ist halt auch krass.
Das verstehen auch wieder die Erwachsenen nicht, also quasi die Eltern. Für die ist das Internet dieser graue Kasten. Und dann schaltet man aus und dann ist das Internet aus. Fernsehen, wie früher Fernsehen. Fernbedienung wegnehmen, die Geschichte ist erledigt. Aber so ist es halt nicht. Weil Smartphones, Internet ist überall. Man geht zum Kumpel zur Not, wenn man sich irgendwie was ziehen möchte, was man daheim nicht darf.
Es gibt eigentlich einfach keine Alternative dazu, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Genau, ganz genau.
Man kann sich das nicht wegwünschen und dann ist es vorbei. Ja, Jungs, super. Tolles Projekt. Wenn jetzt Leute da noch in irgendeiner Form dazustoßen wollen und Bock haben, sich da einzubringen, was wäre so der beste Weg?
Also ccc.de slashschule ist, glaube ich, eine Seite auf der CCC-Homepage, die ein paar Informationen hat. Natürlich auch dann die Verlinkung zu den einzelnen Gruppen, die was machen. Es gibt auf dem...
Die Mailing-Liste.
Von CCC.
Genau, es gibt auf dem Kongress, der gerade stattfindet, einen Workshop zudem.
Mit dieser Sendung hier wird auch nicht aufgezeigt.
Es wird auch mal ein Treffen geben, im vermutlich März irgendwann. Das ist aber noch nicht so ganz spruchreif, aber da wird es auf jeden Fall auch Informationen über die Mailing-Liste von Chaos macht Schule geben. Und wenn man da sich vielleicht subscribt, wenn man Interesse hat, dann...
Zum ersten, vielleicht erst mal zum lokalen RV oder Chaos-Treffgeber, wenn es sowas gibt.
Genau, und dann gucken, was es vor Ort gibt. Da gibt es bestimmt schon eine Menge.
Und sonst noch unsere Homepage.
Genau, wir haben auch unser Shoe-Projekt verlinkt.
Auf cccmannheim.de, was ein Wiki ist.
Genau, slash wiki slash shoe, CMS glaube ich, genau ist das.
Ja, man findet es. Wenn man die Suchfunktion bedienen kann.
Ja, super. Dann sage ich mal vielen Dank. Gerne. Ja, das war es. CRE 189. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis bald.